[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
happy Thursday everybody welcome back to
the junior speed Chess Championship I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend Grandmaster Amman Hamilton
and boy do we have an excellent matchup
for you today they may be Juniors but
gukesh and pranav among their names that
the world should know
they should know and if they don't they
should get to know them but Robert so
excited to be here back commentating
with this jscc and alongside you it's
been a while that they haven't put us in
the box together so excited for today
yeah so am I because it's going to be a
great matchup indeed and I'm excited for
the call these two players had very
different paths towards the semi-finals
of the junior speed Chess Championship
we see in the top of the bracket gukesh
absolutely dumb it in his matchup
against Amin Ohanian he won eight to two
in every time Patrol but you have the
call for pranav in his matchup against
Christopher you that one was a nail
biter
it wasn't I don't mean to brag Robert
but I definitely had the most exciting
round in it you know match up in the
first round 12 and a half to eleven and
a half just a one point margin so you're
right very different paths to get where
they are and I've definitely had a much
closer match but he's also the fifth
seed Robert so now he's got a real test
up against that first seed in gukesh
this is going to be very very close they
often say in competitive events it
doesn't matter how you got there now
that you're here this is the matchup in
front of you we see it's gookesh against
pranav the games will start in just
under 10 minutes but it's the one seed
versus the five among you highlighted
that kukesh we know he's the favorite on
paper but pranav is somebody you've
known in the chess Brock Community for a
long time
he is you know buddy pranav as as we
call him and now buddy pranav is Grand
Master buddy pranav 2600 I mean just
such a rapid rise for both of these
players but uh I think this is going to
be an insanely close match even though
we've got someone in pranav who came in
as a qualifier it was a fifth seed up
against a Titan in gukesh uh Robert I
mean what can you say about good cash
is a superstar I use that word to
describe him very often the other day I
will expand my vocabulary in this match
but he's the youngest player to beat
Magnus Carlson the third youngest GM in
chess history an Olympiad gold medalist
the list goes on and on and last but
certainly not least is that fifth bullet
point he's ranked number 13 in the live
classical ratings he's just 17 years old
Amanda there couldn't be another one
seed in this jscc
amazing yeah I mean the accolades here
are like get them out of the jscc and
put them in the SEC uh I didn't even
know that he was the youngest player to
beat Magnus Carlson so look at me
learning something from the bullet
points here gukesh in first seed I mean
obviously the favorite Robert but let's
not gloss over the accolades of pranav
on the other side I mean you talk about
how kukash brought Rose to what 13
classical ELO how about gaining 127
points in a year's time those classical
ELO points are not easy to come by Arnav
became India's 75th GM last year as well
of course chess 24 Challengers chess
tour Champion which is no easy task and
most importantly want to make sure to
highlight once again that he came to
this jscc through a qualifier Robert so
is it Cinderella story time I thought
you were gonna say most importantly he's
a member of the chess Rock Community
because he really has been there even
before he was a teenager I mean he loves
you guys you've done so many events with
him played him so many times but as you
said to me he earned his spot here this
was not a gimme situation he came
through the qualifier so for pranav it's
been an excellent showing thus far but
he's not somebody who just wants to be
in the main event he wants to win the
main event
yeah that's right I I don't think that
he's coming in with that mentality of
like you know oh were the uh we're the
lowest rated player we're the lowest
seed uh no it's not like that at all uh
I think he's here to win first just as
gukesh is and I think both of these
players have a lot of respect for one
another and know about each other's
talents and abilities so we're
definitely gonna see no one taking their
foot off the gas pedal certainly not
because even the predictions tell the
story that this should be a relatively
close match uh some of the first round
matchups with the exception of the
pronov one were lopsided but here in
ghukesh versus pranab we see that
entering the jscc pranav had the higher
rating between the two now that is
evened up based off of their recent
games but kukesh a slight favorite in
all three time patrols 67 win
probability Oman do you agree with the
looks of these smarter chest predictions
you know what I I really do Robert and I
could say so many good things about both
of these players especially pranav but
at the end of the day gukesh is the
favorite he's proven more he's got a
better track record higher ratings all
around so I think that breakdown is
actually a dare I say it I actually
agree with smarter chess prediction
um but it it all comes down Robert to
you know the match today who's in better
form momentum swings blunders so we
could talk about it on paper but
ultimately the chest does the talking
yeah and you know 67 for one player
means that you win two out of every
three and well this could be the one for
pranav I don't think an upset is out of
the question and it wouldn't even be the
hugest upset in the world despite the
five seed versus the one seed and the
fact that we're not going to qualify he
is really a very strong player and we
should take this moment to remind
everybody what they're about to watch
because this is the speed test
championship format and this winner
advances to the finals at stake in this
particular one it's winner earns four
thousand dollars plus a split of the
other four thousand dollars which is
based on win percentage and when the
event the jscc main event has forty five
thousand dollar prize pool only eight
players a month there's a lot of
programs
there really is Robert and you know
these these players I'm sure they're
focused on uh that top Point getting to
the finals I mean that's what it's all
about but I can't help even as a
commentator focusing on how much is at
stake not just in this match not just in
the overall jscc but in an individual
game the the you know one bullet game
Robert could be like a hundred dollars
yeah there is quite a lot at stake each
and every game a one minute game that
you play that for fun they play it for
money so even down the stretch they will
be playing for a significant chunk of
change and so you will see them trying
to the very end
yeah absolutely I can't wait to get into
this because these players are not going
to be you know taking their foot off the
gas for any reason there is money at
stake and of course I think the match is
going to be really close I don't think
we're gonna see a blowout like we did
see in earlier rounds uh this is an
all-indian matchup which means something
else there will be an Indian player in
the finals so despite having to see one
of them go today I think the Indian fans
have that to console themselves with
yeah chess based India I'm sure is
already ecstatic three out of the four
semi-finals here in the junior speed
test Championship are from India the
fourth player Dennis lesvik from Belarus
and do not count him out he wants to
take down his opposition and win the
crown and no one else is at stake in the
junior speed Chess Championship in each
individual match there's prize money but
the winner of the jscc qualifies for the
speed Chess Championship the main event
gookesh played in that last year he lost
to Magnus Carlson in the first round can
hardly blame him that usually happens to
people with the exception being Hikaru
Nakamura but the other players right
they will not just get automatic
invitations to the speed test
Championship they know that they'll have
to qualify somehow so they would love to
win the junior speeches championship and
earn that automatic invitation
I mean we were talking about Good cash
earlier and I was saying uh yeah I've
seen the accolades I've seen the rating
why don't we just put him in the ICC
already but ultimately I think this is a
really fair way to do it you want to get
in a tournament like that JCC is the
perfect Proving Grounds so to speak
because I mean Robert why do we watch
the jscc because these guys are
unpredictable often underrated ready to
burst onto the chess scene and let
people know that hey you should be
paying attention to me you should know
my name if you don't already and with
this matchup in particular everybody in
the Chess World knows kukesh's name not
everybody knows pronounce if he beats
gukesh everybody will be talking about
him and Buddy he's a great chess player
already but that would be maybe the
highlight of his early chess career to
beat gukesh in a long match this is a
three-time patrol match this is a very
long match where they play three
different time patrols across three
hours that's a very long time so we
should probably remind everybody of the
format of the speed Chess Championship
it's 90 minutes of five minute plus one
second increment followed by an hour of
three minute plus one second added per
move and last but certain at least we
get the bullet of 30 minutes plus one
excuse me 30 minutes of one minute plus
one second added per move so I'm on
we're going to be here for a great show
it's gonna be a long one and for the
players they want to get off to a hot
start because you don't want to slide
into the next time Patrol with a
disadvantage
no I I think I was talking about in
pranav's last match that the five minute
portion I I figured would be the most
impactful and important and I was
hypothesizing that because I think
that's the one that the players actually
don't play they play bullet they play
three minute chess titled Tuesday three
plus one they've seen that time control
before but five plus one I mean my hands
up I've never played a five plus one
game on chess.com and I don't know how
long I've been on the site so uh I I
think that one is actually really
important to pay attention to and it
will be our first time control here and
remember plus one second increment on
every single game so uh you know we
might see some flagging but the players
have to keep in mind that you can live
off that one second increment although
barely
yeah the increment you could live by it
you could die by it and I think one
element of gukash's game that I was
impressed by in The Opening match is he
was very quick that in every single game
in that five minute plus one second
income portion it felt like he was well
ahead in the clock against Amino honey
who is often in the think tank so kukesh
considering that he is number 13 the
live ratings Amman we have to
acknowledge he probably is the better
prepared player between the two he has
more experience at the highest levels so
for pranav in this awkward five plus one
time Patrol how speedy do you think
he'll be especially given you've just
watched him play and defeat Christopher
you and he did very well in that opening
portion
yeah not only did he do well but you
were speaking about the time he was
actually up on time in so many games and
one of the skills that I think obviously
all these players have but I think you
hone this skill more as an online player
which for novice really improved so much
by just volume of games online and I
think the skill that you own by doing
that is being able to use a Time
advantage in your favor being able to
create a position or give your opponent
problems that are just difficult to
solve with 30 seconds with three minutes
on the clock maybe this wouldn't be the
right move but renov really knows when
to oh let's trade the Queens here oh
let's keep the pieces on here and give
my opponent a tougher decision to make
so I think that's honestly one of his
biggest attributes and we may see it on
display here if he can keep up the speed
that's so important to point out because
I watched Dale nerdinsky I have watched
his streams he's a good friend of ours
and I see him in critical moments know
when to trade pieces when to pre-move
when to do the little thing things that
get you victories in time trouble and
the players they're getting set thank
you to everybody at chess.com who's
working so hard behind the scenes to
make sure the players technology is uh
working well to make sure the fair play
check is in order because another thing
that we should mention considering the
short time patrolmon is technology that
pranab he did struggle with that in his
Opening match he cannot afford to
disconnect and lose a game by forfeit
against gukesh yeah I I was gonna bring
that up you know elephant in the room uh
but you're absolutely right that you
know players are responsible for their
connections and uh you know situation
that they play from and pranav did have
not just one but a couple games that uh
you know that the internet actually
played a big role in the game the
problem is even if you don't lose a game
by disconnection Robert it's almost the
threat of the possibility it just plays
into your head every game I was I was
even looking at the match that pranov
played and I was thinking to myself is
he actually playing extra fast because
if he disconnects for a minute or so he
wants to have that buffer of time and I
mean it's those things that you
shouldn't even have to think about
during a match but maybe he is yeah
because chess is a very objective game
and that's a distraction you cannot be
distracted against gukesh you can't
really be distracted against Christopher
you I actually want to highlight just
how impressive that matchup was you had
the call you're covering it the whole
way I watched it the fact that he could
beat Christopher for you who's not just
an amazing player he's also a chess
composer he's created puzzles that have
won awards and these teenagers they're
just that talented and so for pranav to
go in there as you said to be distracted
because the technology issues to
disconnect to Hotspot from his phone I
think that was even more impressive than
just the match-up result on paper he won
by a point but he also had to deal with
those struggles and he overcame them
he did and you know he he ended up
winning the match despite all that so uh
you know huge credit to both players for
an entertaining match Chris for you
almost made the comeback But ultimately
to have all those disconnection issues
and uh you know results be different
than they maybe should have been if it
were played out and still come out on
top is is really impressive you just
have to say that but I'll tell you one
thing Robert I don't think that brunov
can be spotting one-two disconnection
type games to good cash I think he needs
to be connected for every single
possible second during this match and
you know so far I think so good yeah no
he needs not to be just connected but
locked in because you can't take a move
off against kukesh he will punish you
and the players it seems that they are
set we are uh getting get underway in
just about a minute from now so I'm
really excited for this matchup of
modern I guess a question for you we
know cash is the favorite we saw the
smart chest predictions we agreed with
them uh we can see the classical chess
ratings just the successes they've had
over the board what does pranav need to
do to remain competitive and I guess of
question for later is how close does he
need to be heading into bullet to have a
realistic chance
well I'm I'm actually anticipating that
the bullet will be one of renov's
favorite time controls uh don't know
whether it'll be the one that he does
the best in of course but I just think
he is a you know battle-hardened player
online you can see him there on the
camera he's smiling he just looks so
ready to go you mentioned locked in I
think this is even a better mentality
than locked in he's looking dangerous uh
you know ready to play some chess but
also having a good time it doesn't look
too stressed by it because the the last
thing you want Robert is nerves to to
play a factor here oh certainly not but
we just saw a smile from him and we also
saw a tweet earlier uh from somebody
showing a video of pranav and gukesh
sitting side by side and when they were
really kids now they're no longer kids
and chest terms they're super strong uh
they're playing at the top levels of the
game but that was a cute video to watch
and it shows that these two go way back
and that can be uncomfortable for
players right when you play a second of
yours someone you've worked with a
friend of yours it means that you can
give directed by things outside the
chessboard
yeah absolutely I have played against so
many colleagues friends in in chess and
it's always uh you know a little bit
awkward sometimes but the the moves are
on the board we're off here Robert and I
think all the uh the friendliness and
camaraderie is out the window these guys
are true competitors they'll be great
friends as soon as the match is over yes
and look at this opening now that we
have chess in front of us uh black has
delayed castling so the king is in the
center for now and he continues to do so
so Amman with white pushing pawns up the
queen side it seems unlikely the black
goes in that direction but I guess my
question is what is pranav waiting for
to get his kingouts yeah yeah it's
interesting a lot of like Preparatory
moves uh but the position was the nature
of the position was a little bit closed
uh you know there's no Pawn tension
right now at all so I think he felt
comfortable leaving the king there I
thought Robert he was gonna go for that
standard kind of King's Indian plan
maybe move the king to the side bill for
F5 but instead Bishop E6 doubled e-pawns
but an open f file do you like this
structure for black you know it's a lot
of fun for black but objectively I've
always been told that white should be
doing A-Okay and this Knight goes to H5
it might go into F4 later but the
problem really is this bishop on G7 and
look at this with G3 stopping the knight
from getting to F4 and in the long run
Amman that Bishop on G7 the king's
Indian Bishop it's stuck behind a wall
of Pawns
that's right yeah the e-pawn is
basically not going anywhere unless
white were to later play the move d4
meanwhile white has kind of annexed
space on all sides of the board right
now there's D4 maybe in the future the
pawn on A5 gaining so much space on the
queen side but also H4 we might see
Knight H2 Knight G4 there's no G5 for
black so Robert I'm getting the feeling
that white just kind of owns the whole
chessboard I like that 90 shooting
Knight G4 I did keep that in mind
especially now that black went D5
because E5 can be tender but Preparatory
moves is kind of the name of the game
thus far King G2 let's see what black
does before we decide to move overnight
or you can move your queen because the
Knight F3 is defended but I don't know
if I would do that in mono move like
Queen B3 invites an exchange sacrifice
in F3 I would be too scared to allow
that yeah and you mentioned prep moves I
think it's just a move like night one to
uh H2 that is the type of move where you
defend a knight and allow the queen to
move but instead he's chosen Queen E2 a
move in the center and it also eyeballs
that E5 Pawn so potential he takes D5
may be looming in the future I like how
you said Knight one to H2 it you gave it
the emphasis it deserved because it's
sometimes hard to write that on the
notation of wait what's that move called
but yes the Knight F1 went out to H2 The
Rook goes up to F7 so I'm on I think we
see Black's plan it's quite clear bring
pieces to the f file so the question is
does white have enough time to pile up
against this Pawn E5 I love Bishop E3
because it defends F2 and you can go to
C5 to kick a rook out of f8
yeah and no B6 to kick out a bishop on
C5 that's why the pawn is up there what
white would love to achieve is Pawn to
B4 that way everything would be
connected defended and finally that Rook
which right now is tied down A5 could
move okay but we see black thrust that
pawn four with D4 so that pawn on A5
we're talking about it as being an asset
but in end games it could be a liability
there's so many pieces on the board
we're very far from end games but that
pawn A5 sometimes overextended when the
pieces get traded off
yeah absolutely and I was about to
mention an idea for white that black is
basically just quelled with the move E5
which is that if the Knight moved and
white played F4 suddenly it would
actually be white who sort of gains the
king side initiative so E5 although it
takes away squares for Black's pieces
it's kind of important to stop F4
and Knight G1 was played maybe Knight H3
and I wonder if in the future there
could be an F4 but I feel like Knight on
H3 is actually very powerful because it
defends the F2 Pawn he plays Bishop B4
to kick that Rook out of fa we talked
about that idea earlier yeah but I liked
I like the way pranavis played this
buddy is doing well there are no real
weaknesses that can be exploited just
yet in his position and he's keeping
level on the clock is there a move like
C5 here or just thinking Bishop takes 96
and then Knight F4 is Our intention to
win the queen so maybe bishop B4 is like
cool move but is C5 a good move for
black I can't really tell
wow that's a really fascinating idea and
he goes 96 so oh no my Rook on a f8 but
thank you very much for your queen with
Knight F4 checks your idea is perfect
maybe he thought the pawn C5 could be a
weakness because you can't get B6 in to
follow he's just keeping the pawn back
on C7 for now and queen comes Oh I
thought there was Knight F4 check but
then Queen is actually defended thanks
to Knight on H2 yeah I was thinking the
exact same thing uh now obviously black
does need to take Bishop takes f8 into
consideration so finally we do cc5 the
other thing is because the queen is
moved I know we can't do it right now
because the knight's hanging but I'm
starting to look at Queen B5 that just
hits so many tender Pawns
did you see gookest go away from the
board he was distracted by something and
now he's back and trying to regain his
Focus but that was interesting to note
and I'm looking at this position I'm on
I'm with you that Queen coming to B5
later looks very promising for black and
he goes rookie eight perhaps so his next
move can be Queen B5 exactly yeah and
remember that night on H2 if it were for
some reason it played like Knight you
know hf3 Knight F4 check similar idea
you mentioned it earlier like oh that
tactic works but no the knight's
defending the queen so you have to keep
in mind that the Knight needs to remain
defending the queen
so what does white do here because
there's a knight on G1 a knight on H2
there's no attack Brewing on the king
side I feel like Black's Pieces Just
make much more sense thus far yeah and
it's a shame I was gonna ask you that
question but you beat me to it what's
White gonna do well I was thinking about
the move B4 as an idea like you don't
really want to play C4 and I I feel like
if I take the B Pawn and the C pawn and
I take them both off the board that I
like that exchange for white so maybe B4
I like it a lot because when you get B4
in then you open up the B file and the
backwards Pawn on B7 will feel some
pressure but instead we just saw a
repetition that's right rookie eight
Queen D1 uh you know Rook f8 Queen G4 we
might see a draw by repetition which is
kind of interesting at this moment yeah
first of all it's it's interesting
because I actually see a little bit more
long-term potential for Black's position
which is a strange thing to say White's
pieces are I mean everything's solid in
White's position but I don't know to
your point what to do next so I kind of
get why gukesh is repeating and pranav I
like his position he does decide to play
on I mean just a credit to the type of
player he is I think but a draw wouldn't
have been a crazy result
no and you see the question mark which
means it wasn't the best move but we
might give it an exclamation point he is
playing on he doesn't just want to make
a peaceful draw but come on your plan
Rook B1 Pawn to B4 I suddenly am
appreciating White's position more and
more but if you played before now there
is C4 for black yeah the worst trade you
could possibly do for white would be the
d-pawn for the C Pawn so I think that's
to be avoided and not just B4 C4 Robert
I might play C4 anyways
yeah and because you're saying that I'll
play B3 is white instead of going two
squares I'll lift the pawn stop what he
plays before so we are getting this me
too but maybe gukesh sees the forest
through the trees he sees a little bit
further down the line than I am because
it looks like that E4 Pawn now is a bit
tender and that's a healthy protected
passport on D4 for black yeah it's
interesting there's definitely more life
in the position the queen on B3 uh have
to say is quite good
um it's a great diagonal to be on access
to D5 and pronounce says I mean who
cares about the C file if you look at
the squares that can actually be used
there's not much that the Brooklyn C1
can do
no I mean this controlled by every
single Square in that line is controlled
by a black piece so you want to double
to where you're not getting anywhere but
I do like the fact that this white
position is very stable and black has
three Pawn Islands to only two for white
this Knight and F3 may come back to E1
and up to D3 and that Knight on D3 it's
the best way to block hit a pawn is with
a knight absolutely Queen D7 I start to
see shades of Rook takes F3 Knight F4
Queen into G4 and H3 I'm not sure it
quite uh quite works here because of the
hero Queen B3 defending the Knight on F3
but those are the type of things to keep
in mind that you know if we see
something like Queen D5 who knows what
tactics might be looming there wow Queen
E5 is an excellent idea at some moment
in kukesh he hasn't made a move yet uh
we acknowledge that the clocks are on
the screen sorry we are having some
technical difficulties it would appear
but the move plate is Queen to D5 so
Oman you are the gookest prophet at this
point that E5 Pawn is tender in many of
the positions and if you take me on D5
give me that pass Pawn right yeah taking
goes Knight C7 the Knight also has an
interestingly strong Square Knight B5
it's it's a weird one you don't often
see like Knight D5 exclamation mark but
it's it's completely secure there
supports the pawns but remember that
night that was so out of play what the
heck is going on here Knight G4 Robert
tactically working
yes sacrifice and not an F3 to win one
on C7 and we all know about Rooks in the
seventh rank that Rook landing on C7
would be a problem for black so now we
don't have the clock so it's gonna be
apologize for that we'll keep you
updated on the time for novice 59
seconds go cash dropping to a minute
himself but can you push your past Pawn
that's the big question for both sides
is it could be D6 is it gonna be E4 and
D3 or E3 for black I'm not sure Mom yeah
and honestly we might see both maybe D6
E4 could be a reply give that up take
with check and you can go and Corral
that pawn after so I mean we might see
literally everything you just said
Robert
okay and we note that gukesh is now down
to 36 35 seconds he needs to find an
idea because this can get out of hand
quickly when you don't have time to
calculate yeah I I think at this point
it's uh down to nerves because this is
time scramble and oops that's me playing
D3 not these guys we see D6 played
Knight B5 I'm getting excited here
Robert as we're in time scramble mode
only 25 seconds for good cash and there
may not be Queens but there are tactics
all across the board and pranav he is 45
seconds of the black pieces he's
thinking about what to do he takes on D6
giving up E5 so now I really do like
White's position a healthier Pawn
structure and some activity for those
pieces yeah I think that's a very
beneficial trade the pawn on D4 yes it's
a pass Pawn but it has so many obstacles
in its path pieces blockading it so I
agree now I'm looking at the Knight on
H5 Robert and thinking man that is so
out of play it really is and both sides
at 25 seconds everybody this will come
down to a Time scribble there could be a
blunder we see a take on F6 The Rook on
E1 defensive Knight D7 or Knight G4 are
ideas to try to win an exchange at some
point yeah that would you need to move
the Rook there this bishop on G7 hasn't
been in a good all game and Rook C7 with
some pressure there now I'm thinking
Knight G4 and the H6 Pawn might be loose
okay we see the point up to F4 now
pranav down to 17 seconds white about
the same both players in time travel who
is going to take this one that Knight on
D6 a month and go to F5 some yeah it can
hop around the board absolutely the
knights are so dangerous and time
scrambles and you know at this point I
was about to say are we gonna see G5 to
just you know launch everything into
disarray to steal one from Candy G5 we
live Bishop takes E5 on this turn and
right now white down to 11 seconds black
has 11 seconds as well time pressure for
both we are seeing exchange of the
Knight on D6 is loose watch out for a
fork but no we have seen liquidation a
month whose chances do you like better
well honestly I think White's a little
bit better here because of the weak Pawn
but I gotta be honest with you Robert I
like the Knight yeah me too and six
seconds for white 11 for black G4 play
Rook G5 takes G4 at some point but watch
out there was rookie two checks so
that's what yeah rookie four would be a
way to attack B4 right now exactly and
at this point if the Rooks trade white
has to be so so careful Robert because
an end game might just be a disaster for
the bishop
yeah but look at the white Rook swinging
across the board G4 is loose oh oh Rook
C4 winning B4 we are gonna have pawns on
opposite side of the board here is A5
gonna fall as well well the other thing
is that the bishop will be taking here
and hang on a sec takes Rook F5 holds
things together
yes and two seconds for black five for
white they both are scrambling one
second at it for each and every move
they make so now black suddenly with
three seconds white with four now up to
five wow they're really moving fast and
you can take that Bishop off the board
but he elects to keep the Knight on
probably a smart decision what the heck
is happening there's Knight D7 65. so
black is taking this one he wins a
bishop and wins game one and both
players were down to their final seconds
pernav takes game one with black Amman
you said it he is here to play
unbelievable yeah that's like what uh
game one Robert is that not an
indicative of the match that we're about
to have here I think the one thing I'm
really paying attention to though in
this match so far is that time scramble
who seemed calmer who played the the
more calm collected moves and just you
know basically didn't panic and in that
one I think it was print off
yes that was a really nice game from
pranav the way he handled that uh he
never really was worse there so uh they
are beginning game two I believe
um and so as soon as that comes up we
will bring it up for you but wow pranav
leads after the first game of the match
he wins with black and smarter chest
prediction said gookash is the favorite
he still is but pronounces I don't care
what you say this thing yeah he says
yeah uh favorite uh yeah that's that's
what stats are for I'll show you what it
means to actually play this thing but
you know we don't want to get hired over
ourselves it is only game one after all
yes and well it seems like game two is
beginning we apologize everybody we are
dealing with some technical issues and
we're trying to fix them live in the fly
uh so
um apologies we are really doing our
best in the moment but Amman pranav
takes game one there that's a good news
for him yeah but gukesh you know we know
that he's had some difficulties before
it's not the first time he suffered
defeat in fact he had one of the most
agonizing defeats of his life in the
Olympiad when he lost it no dear Beck
Abdus Atari when he had the upper hand
all game there
exactly and uh you know I think at this
point the I believe that the players are
in the game so that's that's something
that that I think I can say like based
on the Expressions there nobody just
looks at a computer screen that intently
yeah no I mean uh we are about to bring
up game two for everybody again
apologies but I think it's uh going to
be available shortly so uh yeah it's a
rough start for gookesh and for him well
we we know how hard he works on his game
and here is game two and so he is the
black pieces and he has the advantage if
you see the eval bar off the side saying
black is better the big question right
now is can black take on B2 with the
queen because it's hanging but sometimes
that's a queen that gets into enemy
territory and doesn't get to escape and
just for the people at home Robert and I
mean myself as well what am I saying
this is a selfish decision I'm going
back to the start just for a quick run
through of our moves here it was a
Sicilian
interesting we get one of these
rosalimos with Bishop to B5 and man this
stuff is always so interesting Robert
because Black's Pawn structure is just
some of the weirdest stuff you'll ever
see it's like how many opening
principles are being broken in this game
these are Grand Masters
yeah but this is Gucci's beloved opening
I've seen him on the blacks of this very
often and you see him jettisoned upon
with C4 to get that Queen B6 check Queen
takes B2 and now that we're here Amon I
mean this position does look very hectic
there's Pawn tension in the center C2 is
loose there's a queen on H5 which I know
would scare much of our audience
thinking am I gonna get checkmated right
but a lone Queen can't deliver a mate
and unfortunately for white there's no
Knight jumping into G5 there's a pawn F6
stopping that exactly and the position
let's say that pawn captures on C6
Bishop captures on C6 if you move that
Bishop
hello Checkmate on G2 so the game could
end just that quickly and let's not
forget you know some basic principles
Robert for all our viewers two Bishops
open position yeah one plus one equals
two
yep one plus one does equal two unless
you're taken to that deep dark forest
and then who knows what Mikhail tall was
thinking but that's the type of magic
that white will need to drum up here is
that tall magic getting an attack but
there is no there's literally no way in
for white I love this position for
gukesh his time management is excellent
he's a little bit ahead in the clock and
now it's about winning this position
because aesthetically pleasing we have a
bishop pair but if we trade too many
pieces then we may liquidate into a
position where white can hold and so
black needs to be on the offensive yeah
and the the one thing that black always
has in his favor here is gukesh's Bishop
the light squared Bishop will always be
strong because of f4 there's never an F3
move to blunt this diagonal and as I say
that he gives the bishop away and I
don't agree with that move
the evil bar also disagrees and he
steals a pawn so sometimes they say
greed is good but here it seems to have
given white a leg right back in the game
and I'm already wondering is there going
to be a d takes C6 at some moment will
that be available that will be a pass
pawn and he starts with Rook C1 so wait
a second where's this queen going right
I mean yeah Queen B2 and is there
anything first of all taking on F4 and
just playing Queen F3 it's like yeah
there might be a pawn down position for
white but I don't even hate that
whoa but he chases the queen away and
the queen could have gone back to C2 but
that probably would have resulted in a
draw with a rook and queen dance over
there so the queen escapes out to A3 can
white just take that pawn on C6 now I
was wondering just a moment ago what
happens if white ends up with a pawn all
the way up there the Eva Bar says equal
but to my eyes Iman it's anybody's game
yeah totally agree I mean Pawn takes C6
looks very okay white species will be a
little awkward in that position you know
the the king always has back rank issues
but the queen on H3 defending the Knight
and maybe there's an E6 check in the
future we have to be careful this
doesn't even flip in White's favorite
completely I did not like Bishop takes
H3 I was too busy complimenting that
Bishop I didn't even consider that move
yeah you never would have done it that
was clear and I think it was a decision
that gukesh will regret because you look
at the position now he had full control
over the board that was a knight on H3
that couldn't do anything and I think
that's a good lesson for everybody that
kukesh did it to try to win a pawn but
the material was not worth it and in
fact he ends up not even upon ahead
because that potency six was just
captured so if kukesh had a retry or a
reset button he would immediately be
pressing it he'd be smashing that button
and saying I will keep that light Square
Bishop I don't care if I'm down a pawn
I'd rather have that light Square Bishop
on the board with the open space agreed
yeah no he's he's wishing he could go
back in time but that is quite literally
the opposite mentality you want to have
right now you hate to lament the
decisions of the past he's got to focus
on what's in front of him and what's in
front of him is not a position that's
lost or anything of that nature just yet
however I do think his next couple moves
here are super important Robert probably
has to be very accurate I mean we need
to Corral this Pawn but there's so many
nice options for white here Queen E6
Knight into D5 so he's chosen a knight
on a great anchor Square on E5 honestly
it looks like a pretty reasonable
decision what's wrong with it it
received a question mark I'm not
entirely sure my instinct would be C7
because I can follow up with Knight to
D5 to defend that pawn up on C7 and he
plays it and the eval Bar says nope
that's not right Robert what do you
think of that well I I really uh got you
hook line and sinker with that one get
Robert to commit to a move live on air
and find out that it's wrong uh but he
went for your move as well which just
shows that intuition is not always what
the engine is looking for this but
required a little more accuracy because
okay Queen E6 suddenly your knight is
hanging as well and if you jump into D5
the amazing move Queen A5 is now hitting
the Rook on D2 so what a fine by ukesh
there and it looks like he had that move
ready to go
yeah I mean what a natural move C7 was I
mean you're pushing Upon A passer one
square away from promotion so let's see
what can white do now you can bring your
B1 Rook up to B7 to defend the pawn but
that's so risky because of back rank
checkmates yeah Queen A6 and it's like
oh wait a minute you know the best move
there might be bringing the roof back
are we gonna see the most professional
draw in history Rook B7 Queen A6 Rook B1
Queen A5 yes or no
I actually think that makes perfect
sense you know how I feel about early
draws but this may be what the position
calls for but what else can white do
maybe Queen E6 check over to D6 that
does defend that wait did I just drop my
knight on C3 yes I did so you were just
saying how you shouldn't do that but I
did just drop the Knight on C3 so okay
what wait wait wait a second a month
that might work I blundered but it
actually might work out let's bring up
the analysis board I like because I like
where we're going here yeah because
black has some background problems of
his own so if Queen E6 check right King
to h8 Queen to D6 Queen this might
happen by the way Queen yeah queen queen
takes f8 does this work for white
Rook d8 at the end there are back rank
issues but you're just getting no credit
here is Queen you know why cc5 is not
the move either it's what happens here I
think is King G8 and after Rook takes f8
King f8 a rook B8 check King F7 white
gets back ranked checkmated after
promote goodness
just have to show a line like this
and it's like you know White's finally
happy about the material only to be met
with this let's get back to the action
here check
Queen D6 brilliancy Queen takes on C3
and Rook B8 so we're following your line
but with a slight Improvement because
pranov spent time calculating that look
at White's time down to 23 seconds but
Robert he's found something that the
engine says is equal but black has to
find it yeah how is this equal I just
don't understand what's going on here
now there I think what is going to
happen is Queen C1 check Rook D1 will
block and you sack your queen for the
rook and you have to take this Rook
twice on B8 so it'll be a rook Knight
and pawn for a queen when all is said
and done I that's equal according to the
evaluation bar but the position remains
very difficult for black yeah you know
black basically wants to establish some
position where the Rook ends up maybe on
D7 that way would be guarding the pawn
the Knight guarding the Rook the pawn
guarding the Knight and then you just
hope to shake hands and and make a draw
but first of all you have to come to
terms that you are ready to sack your
queen and that's your only option
yeah but that setup that you just
mentioned that's a fortress so if
blackened establish that then a game
should be held without too much
difficulty and we should note that a
knight a rook and a pawn for Queen
that's even by point value more or less
but what we also need to tell was a
knight and Rook can team up in a way of
Queen can so it's not just a one-sided
fear but black now is down to about 10
seconds a month he needs to find the
move yeah honestly Queen C1 I mean I was
about to say does he even see it and I
think he saw it and was looking for
better couldn't find it eventually said
okay this needs to be done
yeah and I think he's going to play Rook
to B7 as long as your Rook doesn't hang
it's some kind of queen check you put
that Rook on D7 or F7 and that's all
black needs to do Rook D7 Rook F7 Rook
D7 Rook F7 I don't think white can do
anything at all no the only plan to try
to you know
do anything to that setup would be
pushing these pawns and maybe trying to
play G5 much later in the game
um interesting to play G6 but honestly
King goes to G7 Rook goes to D7 and I
think we can basically say that this one
is a draw
yeah it seems to be a fair result maybe
it was much easier defensive task than
initially realized in gukesh he could
play for more it's not out of the
question he is building what appears to
be the start of a mating net around the
white king so I think Punjab has to be
careful Knight F3 check rookie one mate
is coming that's true you could play
Queen E6 so casually here but black also
has to be careful you give up that a
pawn and everything crumbles
yeah so Rook D1 he can go Rook D2 after
okay he's just going back and forth he
knows that this setup is just a draw for
black but with the King going up to F5
so that's what I'm wondering yeah I'm
just gonna bring my king out like uh why
is the king hiding on H2 it feels that
only bad things could happen there
I'm with you and so black is just going
back and forth white is kind of doing
the same so it does feel like we're
about to see a repetition and we do yeah
and by the way that Queen Sacrifice from
gukesh the only option in that position
and a brilliancy so both players finding
brilliances your intuition was spot on
Robert with that Queen E6 Queen D6 I
mean that was just a high quality game
and surprise surprise high quality chess
from both players ends in a draw
yeah these two players off to a very
well played start uh gukesh of course on
the scoreboard down by a point but that
first game it did feel like initially he
was out playing pranav a little bit but
then pranav held sturdy a very nice
defense by him and now in game three
this opening of mine white has the pair
of Bishops you see that now the queen
and Bishop are lined up towards H7 the
bishop on B2 if you ever played D5 will
open up towards the black king so don't
take on G2 would be my advice to
everybody yeah and you know what white
had the option after Bishop B7 to Castle
defending G2 and he's actually foregone
that move for multiple moves in Arona
which is an interesting practical
decision he wants life to take and you
know what as the captain black piece is
here Robert that would make me not want
to take that pawn even more yeah and
look at this castling Queen side and
shout out to our chat we see you feature
chat there crazy good end game by both
Indian prodigies it certainly was that
was excellent play from both and now
that you've Castle Queen side him on
you're not taking on GT two is black you
gave up that pawn you want open lines
people think oh I lost material you did
lose that but you gained open lines for
your Rooks yeah and Rook to G1 that's
not a oh let me defend my pawn move
that's a I wish this Pawn could actually
just disappear from the G file because
he wants to play G4 G5 and that would
immediately create a threat on H7
and look at this position with the
tension the center I was about to say
must black release it and he does and
after he takes D4 maybe black will play
D5 and shut in that Bishop on B2 so you
think okay if you want to shut down my
Bishop let's take with the bishop on D4
but that has other problems you give
black the E5 Square for the Knight for
example so it's a big moment and good
cash has slowed down I think this is
very instructive for everybody watching
you don't simply recapture you need to
think about which piece to to take with
it will change the direction of the game
yeah the bishop captures on D4 and move
I definitely am sure that that will be
worse decision than Pawn takes but I I
totally understand why he played it
because why would you not want your
piece to enjoy this amazing open
diagonal he saw e takes D4 and D5 as you
mentioned and probably thought okay my
Bishop's Never Gonna See the Light of
Day again
right but look what he's allowed because
the bishop rather than a Pawn on D4
black is prying open the queen side and
the bishop goes back to the corner so we
see the eval bar but Iman I think you
and I have played enough Blitz chess in
our day to ignore that for now because
the game will not be decided at this
current stage you look at the pressure
that white has down the queen side but
look what black is doing striking first
on the queen side yeah I was really
wrestling in my head is it B5 or D5 that
black wants to play I was leaning
towards the d-pawn but either way C5 is
impossible black could take and Rook C8
is happening so it means that black now
has kind of an open a file a little bit
upon running down the board uh
semi-opened B file and a wide open C
file I mean what's going on here how was
White's King even allowed to pee on the
queen side right now yeah he went for a
king-site attack but he allowed black to
hit his stride and Bishop F5 so he
sacrificed the pawn has gukesh but we
know what he wants he wants G5 and the
H7 Pawn will be loose if black plays G6
you're not even going to take this
bishop 105 and open up your king but you
also open that dark Square diagonal so
I'm on this is a good moment for Buddy
for pranav to sit and think because this
is a critical moment of this game three
yeah a move like 95 comes to mind you
know maybe Knight D3 looking to sack one
of these Bishops and open up a line to
the king you know Robert when they say
that you're supposed to Castle so that
you have three Pawns in front of your
king I don't think these are the three
they were talking about
no not at all it's a very nasty looking
position for that white King on C1 you
would like to teleport it but actually
I'm on where could you even put that
King that is safely A3 might be the
safest way I know it's like there's not
many options here you got to choose the
lesser of two evils I like to move 95
throw an extra piece on that long
diagonal and maybe indeed look to play
Move Like Knight D3 or Pawn to C3 get
one of these Bishops off the board
because they're so strong
yeah and he just goes Knight D5 giving
up H7 with check that's one measly Pawn
but B4 is a more important Pawn black is
going right after the white king you
mentioned C3 is an idea there are too
many options available to Black so
gukesh he takes that pawn we look at
this position and I think how is this
King going to survive because he doesn't
have pieces in front of it that will
help in the defense yeah and I actually
made a casual arrow on the last move
King h8 but really important to point
out that I think pranav's move is so
much better King h8 just unnecessary to
be on that diagonal and to allow things
like Queen E4 Queen H4 and suddenly you
have a lot to worry about so good heads
up play by uh pranav I think with King
f8 and now uh sorry gukesh you gotta
face the music you've been attacking the
last couple of moves I think we need
some defense and what defense can he
possibly get here because his King on C1
feels a bit alone and C3 is an option
Knight D3 check Still Remains available
G6 for black made lock in that Bishop on
H7 and that's important the King goes on
f8 so kukesh takes on E5 if Rook takes
E5 what is the follow-up here you know
the question is like is Knight takes C4
really the move because while that looks
like a threat I mean I don't think
opening the C file is in White's
interest at all so you're in this
annoying position where black can
basically keep throwing pawns at you
because you never want to take them
they're actually the shelter for your
King right now
yeah they're the most umbrella for the
rainstorm that's going against your king
that you'll get but you're dropping B4
next I don't think there's a way around
it so this king is never going to find
safety I I don't know I know I don't
like calling game over but this looks to
me like its game it really does I'm I'm
struggling to see because the thing is
even if pranav doesn't play you know the
best continuations this position in
front of us is what we knew would happen
a wide open King and you just can't
possibly do anything about it
no Queen takes before Rook takes C4
check will be the response and black
will get a queen for a couple Rooks but
Black's King is safe whites King is open
and when you talk about material
imbalances you have to First Look whose
King is safer yeah and it appears that
black Singh Is much safer if White's
Queen were to leave the board absolutely
and the Queen and Bishop would be all
over the position let's not forget G6 at
some point will trap that bishop and
black has a past a pawn that needs uh
needs someone to deal with it so yeah I
agree with you even though the material
does look even there I think black's
completely winning
I like that move Rook D4 though because
you defend your knight directly that way
you don't give up your queen and B4
Knight is hanging behind it a bishop is
loose and that Rook on D4 at the right
moment can swing over to H4 like if you
play Bishop back to C2 to shelter your
king then Rook H4 suddenly white can go
on the offensive that's right no you
can't uh discount can't discount that D5
to put more pressure on the Knight it's
easy to lose track your knight is also
hanging and hang on the King on f8 is
really poorly placed for that so an
important decision here even though the
engine is like screaming in Black's
favor uh gookesh is gonna make him earn
it but time on the clock Robert not
basically has double the time of his
opponent right now he needs to use that
against them this is one of those areas
that I was saying I think pranav is one
of the best
and guest just had his eyes closed he
was clearly calculating some lines and
this is why I don't call game before
it's over look at this position suddenly
I'm looking at like doesn't white have
some chances here Bishop D5 by Buddy he
says take on B4 the same thing is going
to happen I'm going to take on C4 and
you can't really afford to take back
because white will lose the queen down
to see I see the question mark I
disagree with it from the pragmatic
perspective of the fact that it keeps
Black's King very safe it keeps the
attack going and I really don't see what
white is going to do to keep his King
guarded so I think it's still Advantage
black and maybe not the best move but
still a good move I think King D2 here
and I don't know from a practical
perspective I feel like white is kind of
in this game King D2 threatens the piece
you've got D6 stuff looming as well and
the bishop is you know a square away
from getting back but actually takes on
C5 something I didn't consider at all
wait but he just loved G6
he totally forgot is this yeah his line
was actually so good there Robert he
just needed to bring the bishop back
first an oversight honestly
yeah it is a great idea trying to get
down to this end game and he was so
worried about that outside pass pawn and
I would be too that he forgot that his
Bishop was about to get trapped so he
stopped the outside pass Pawn but he's
going to be down piece and look at this
Rook D2 check is such a strong with
forced resignation he could have won the
bishop but the bishop was locked in
there not going anywhere let's grab some
pawns first and pranav is out to a
two-point lead he is and uh gukash I was
actually about to say was doing the
unthinkable somehow coming back from
that position Robert which is just
insane to me he had no cover for his
King he actually turned that into a
match but just that sinking feeling when
you make that comeback but in the final
step when you just need to bring your
Bishop back and it was anyone's game to
play for I think oops uh he just he got
it trapped and totally forgot about it
so just a moment of blindness for kukesh
as pranav jumps out to a big lead
yes and go cash is the black pieces in
this one he plays his standard opening
we get a sicilian and he has those
doubled C pawns and Amman look at that
last move Queen C7 he is allowing his
pawns to get doubled in isolate on the C
file still right now to me that seems
unacceptable but kukesh he knows what
he's doing how can he afford to have
double isolated pawns like that yeah
well obviously the it's sort of position
specific but one thing that that is the
case in White's position is after you
play C3 and maybe take here the light
squares are going to be permanently a
little bit weaker than you'd like them
to be like C4 like D3 uh and you know
the two Bishops for black we saw that
dynamic in the previous game in this
opening so it does favor Black in the
sense that it opens things up and those
weak light squares he's going to look to
take advantage of so really excited for
this game because the middle game
Roberts can be all about very very
different Dynamic strategies
yeah and the position that we have right
here I would say that both sides have
their specific advantages for black you
have that Bishop pair but that light
Square Bishop that we're talking about
that's the extra Bishop so to speak in
the position yeah where is it going you
don't have A6 and if you play A5 that
feels overly committal on the queen side
so he starts at The Rook B8 but Knight
C4 you protect B2 you start striking
towards the center on E5 I really like
this position for white yeah I think
what might need to happen is ultra
aggression I'm talking about F5 so maybe
Knight C4 F5 just strike at that E Pawn
if Pawn takes then the bishop finally
develops there's always tactics like
Bishop takes H3 with a loose Knight on
F3 so are we gonna see something as as
crazy as F5 either either now we're in a
couple moves
yeah to have any sort of active play you
might need to do that uh the Knight on
G6 can also go up to F4 and then we'll
have two Bishops against two knights if
white decide to take it so there's some
big decisions that will be made shortly
and I want to give a shout out to Daniel
nerdinski because Dania often says that
pawn structure is the most overrated
thing in chess Black's Pawn structure is
clearly terrible those doubled C pawns
that are isolated the a pawn is also
isolated but black is all this activity
thanks to the bishop pair and so white
can't take full advantage of those pawns
they're not loose they're not under
attack so I think that black as you said
Can strike with F5 at the right moment
but considering that he's delayed it I
don't think he's gonna do it yeah and I
I don't know if this is uh correct or
not but I'm getting the feeling that
black not striking with F5 is sort of in
White's favor I feel like the more sort
of Meandering maneuvering type of Chess
that we get here the more it favors
White's position because structurally
you're good so I feel like black has to
strike quickly to try to take advantage
of that active pieces Queen is way on
the Queen side uh I'm waiting for F5 so
if we don't see it soon Robert I'm
actually wondering what Black's up to
yeah because F5 seems to be the only
active choice but also has a big
downside the E5 Pawn will be loose it
will not have another Pawn to defend it
so now the Knight has gone to D2 F5 I
think that white can even just play F3
just keeps solid on the king side you
can also take on a five at any moment as
we keep discussing so can black just do
nothing that's maybe the question that
needs to be asked is can black just sit
and wait and he plays Bishop G5 goes
active in another way but Amman what is
White's breakthrough plan well one thing
I'd love to do with the white pieces is
Queen A3 and queen C1 and queen C2 just
totally get my queen out of there I'm
not a huge fan of the queen on A4 at the
moment I think the Rook is you know
doing a good job just kind of making the
queen more or less useless there uh so
and he kind of goes for Queen A3 I think
that makes a lot of sense the Queens are
worst piece try to improve it yeah the
queen was offside he gets a question
mark the idea is good perhaps it was the
wrong moment right and I think it's
because the Black Knight is about to
sink its teeth into F4 and that's such a
juicy square and then we're talking a
potential attack for black when the
queen slides to E7 over to G5 suddenly
that white king might feel a little bit
of pressure and is it I was about to say
is it so much pressure that you would
even consider F takes E3 there getting
your own set of double isolated pawns
obviously pronov keeps it cool you know
he wants to keep the pun structure
intact but that would be a consideration
considering how nasty this looks I'm
with you and queen E7 would be my move
for black it's uh kind of the main idea
but Knight takes E5 is there needs to be
calculated at the very least I think
black is okay with those Queen G5 ideas
but you don't want to drop a pawn the
center and then calculate afterwards you
need to calculate in advance exactly
um there are some ideas like sacrifices
on H3 and you know I think the most
annoying thing for black is this
Brooklyn B5 can't ever really slide
across the board there's no easy way to
do that so the fact of the matter is it
will take so long for a rook to join uh
for black if a rook could get to G6 or
something I think the attack would be uh
very promising
and wow look at this move Rook d8 he
offers a trade and A7 would drop at the
end of the line but that Queen gains
access over to G5 so I guess gukesh
assessed the position what trades
benefit me getting one pair of Rooks off
the board because that Rook on D1 it
could have jumped up to D6 at some
moment and started pressurizing the
black queen side so I like that move
rook d8 and I'm not sure if white can
afford to grab that pawn on A7 after The
Rook trade and so I'm kind of wondering
like after Queen G5 uh King H2 are we
really threatening anything like one
thing that is true there is that Bishop
takes C4 means Pawn has to take back and
I I think we're starting to get a feel
uh for Black's counter play Queen takes
d8 let's say queen A7 black might want
to play Queen G5 Bishop takes and invade
with the Rook for a pawn I'll take that
trade oh yeah and there could also be
Bishop takes H3 and queen H4 tactics so
you have to look out for sacrifices for
opening of the file so The Rook gets
involved so that's why pranava slowed
down and I think it's right that we
mentioned that now cash is up over a
minute on the clock we've seen pretty
level time management from the players
thus far but I think kukesh the
trajectory of this game is going in his
favorite now that he's landed that
Knight on F4 exactly it's so annoying
because there's no G3 to kick it out H4
to play G3 and you're just weakening so
many light squares around the king so
the Knight is fairly permanent and
meanwhile whitesnite on E3 we've been
talking about how bad the pawn structure
is for black how about how good it is
the Pawn on C6 covering D5 is actually a
hero right now
yeah and white is a king H2 is that I
like that's a preemptive move a lot of
these ideas were talking about with the
queen game in G5 you take advantage of
the G2 Pawn was pinned so King H2 played
I think it's I was gonna say Rook B5
back to B8 but that drops the C5 Pawn
that's not a pawn I want to give up
though there are Knight D3 Forks in the
air so this is a big moment for black
yeah that's Rook V8 might be actually
quite clever uh because black really
wants to play Queen E7 but I'm just not
sure about 95 now that the king's on H2
yeah no the king is running away from
many of the threats and gukesh is
thinking right now he's still up a
minute on the clock
um
95 maybe Queen E7 and sort of invite
this and head back to C7 if this Pawn is
captured because then maybe you you
eyeball the King on H2
it's a really good point that the queen
doesn't have to go just up to the G file
to go back to the diagonal so that stops
at Knight takes E5 so that would make me
more likely to play Queen E7 but now I'm
thinking again about those Queen takes
A7 lines not the Kings on H2 is that a
better variation for white the queen
would still go over to H4 that does
scare me and it's like all these
questions we're asking yeah these guys
have to actually answer them we can just
ask them
yeah no and it's very consequential you
lose the A7 Pawn as black and he goes
Queen E7 you might lose the game because
an a-pawn passer down the line will win
for white or you have enough counter
play on the king side so he decides
after calculation that's worth it in a
month white is down under a minute with
this many pieces on the board yeah I
think that this is the right decision by
gookash I think this position is
trending in his favor and as the time
gets lower I think the attacking
position that he has gets better and
better and better so that was a question
mark the queen goes up to G5 threatening
Checkmate in one which of course
probably novel not miss that and so what
happens if the knight from C4 goes to E3
I feel like white is doing a decent job
of stabilizing but he just goes back to
G3 with the Knight and H5 H4 and you're
you're drawing the arrows right as I was
thinking it I'm on this is starting to
look better and better for gukesh right
and after H5 is it almost forced I think
we need to play Knight E3 to guard G2 I
mean Rook G1 is possible but Knight E3
makes a lot more sense leaving The Rook
on the open file and getting the the
Knight off that square so now I'm
wondering do we take this moment right
to capture on C4 what do you think of
that one I like it because strategically
black is in huge trouble if Checkmate
doesn't happen and the Queens go off the
board then black is in a world of hurt
so in Bishop takes C4 at least levels up
the pawns over there on the queen side
he plays H5 he's going for the check
Medias but suddenly Amman it's gukesh
Who's down on the clock yeah and I think
that was a missed opportunity not
capturing that Knight because black had
all the pressure here capture the knight
move the Rook you don't care about those
pawns H5 H4 is coming now we have 93
defending beautifully so it's anyone's
game whoa the Knight on E2 Queen F4
check is a huge threat Knight takes C3
that's a hanging Pawn as well so how
does white deal with all of a sudden
once Queen B2 they're still Queen F4 he
takes on A7 ignores his King I mean he's
going for F7 and he says okay you can
try to mate me I can try to mate you is
white not delivering a Checkmate here
because black doesn't have a draw
oh my goodness no this is good for white
all of a sudden down under 20 seconds is
good cash he might have to play Rook B8
but that's a sad move to play when
you're on the offensive Queen E3 Queen
H6 after check and the E2 Knight hangs
unbelievable
yes so he goes Rook to B8 pranav is
about double the time now he's done 23
seconds he has all sorts of checks in
front of the black king but I'm not sure
it amounts to much of anything just yet
yeah I missed after Queen E3 there's
just Queen G6 and mate so that's why
Rook uh B8 was played to cover Rook d8
but I mean F6 uh Knight G4 there's so
many moves here yeah Knight F6 check and
Knight H6 check are both thread you
can't stop what do you do here is Black
by the way is it actually made after
Knight H6 or Knight F6 I don't I don't
know if it is you almost have to play
Knight F1 and just hope no but you take
a knight of six King f8 Knight D7 check
you grab that Rook over there on B8 wow
yeah
Knight F6 he goes for Knight D7
and take he wants to avoid the draw
there's no way he repeats with Knight H7
here
he goes forward he understands that the
best black has is a draw against the
white king but now it Knight B8 Queen F4
King G1 doesn't King actually Escape I
think it might here it feels like he
does but I this is one of those things
Robert you don't calculate obviously
just go for it oh the evil bar oh look
at it he's so upset with himself he's
like why did I bring my king to E3 not
to F3 to start with and King E4 was mate
by the way do not play King before no
the queen E2 made it
slip Queen B1
oh
well he's he's winning now completely
bring the queen back somewhere to E2
yeah
what a mouse slip
and he's already down two points he's
supposed to be down three points pronov
is just really off to the best start you
could possibly imagine oh my goodness
yeah the King goes to B2 and now or C2
and now you're fine
yeah you run away and there are no more
checks
still a game to play here Queen E5 but
definitely I mean just so much progress
made after that Mouse slip heartbreaking
yeah and oh a night Fork at the end to
win it pranav is up three and a half to
half Amman we could not have seen this
coming no the I mean the number one seed
has not won a chess game Robert look at
pranav on camera he's got that look of
determination he knows what he just did
he was hanging himself in the moment for
missing that opportunity to maybe find a
better king move and play for a win a
draw was on the board but the
unthinkable happened Robert a mouse slip
with a perpetual
wow so pranav leads by three foot points
some disappointments chess players are
always perfectionist he doesn't have to
have a perfect four to four a three and
a half will do and as we head to break
the players we'll get a bit of rest when
returned the five minute plus one second
added per move increment will continue
here at the junior speeches Championship
semi-final match between gukesh and
pranav
[Music]
18 seconds for a black so not too much
time there either Rook C7 a7's falling
uh it is E4 it pushes the pawn this is
getting a little messy takes a knight F1
move oh my gosh 0.9 seconds when that
move was played
King C2 and run the key three four takes
it
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was me and instead he
played here and you're not losing a lot
of time oh my God A7 wins for white oh
my gosh
[Music]
I really love watching games by top
female players and studying their games
in the past and I think that's like one
really cool thing that the test
Community could do more of I know my
friend Luciana is publishing a testable
course on some of the great games by the
early world champions veravan chicko and
you can learn just as much from these
games as you can learn from any game and
yet it does provide inspiration and like
adds like depth to our chess culture so
I about 10 years ago I published a book
called play like a girl with like
tactics by female chess players and
actually redoing that book and it's so
much fun to just like kind of like dig
in and see some of the most important
tactical themes in chess decoy in
between move pins
double attacks and to look for like some
of the the best examples by top female
players so when you hear all these
discussions about women in jazz it's
great sometimes I'm just like wow you
should just like go study some music
games
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
here in the junior speed Chess
Championship currently pranav leads
gukesh three and a half to half a month
we don't want the platitudes oh one move
at a time my question for you is what
does gukesh have to do to turn this
match around
well I think if you really look at what
has gone wrong in these first couple
games obviously the last game we can
fully chalk it up to a mouse slip that
was in my opinion kukesh's best game
um but he just didn't find that decisive
move uh Bishop takes Knight that I was I
was looking for from I think he would
have won that game if he did that but
that was his best game I think he really
played well there uh the the attacking
positions seemed to suit him so I don't
think he needs to change anything but if
this match was you know a little bit
different he he wins that last game
Robert I don't even think we'd be having
this conversation just a slow start so I
think at the moment just don't get too
frustrated over that Mouse lip and know
that this match is a lot closer than the
score reflects yeah yeah and I think
that pranav who we see on camera right
now has just been the more consistent
player uh now slips aside I just like
the way he's been handling those tense
moments it seems like his defense is up
to par and he leads three and a half
that's no accident I do think that he
has played great chess today so for
gookesh you know he has all the trophies
in the world behind him he won't add the
junior speed chess champion title to his
resume if he doesn't turn it around
starting right now
do they make trophies for that damn
that'd be a sweet looking trophy uh but
you're absolutely right Robert you know
all jokes aside we could say that this
match is closer than the score reflects
and I believe that but ultimately that's
not gonna change the score he's got to
go out there and do it and uh he's going
into this next game he'll have the white
pieces is it safe to say that this is
like a maybe a must not lose game yes I
would definitely consider it that and we
see the game is starting and gukesh he
gets the white pieces he chooses D4 and
a solid start to the game I think that's
what he needs he just needs to get a
rhythm and down three points that sounds
bad but there's so much time left in
this match
yeah no there's there's lots of time uh
left actually what we see on the board
here is kind of interesting because if
the bishop were on G5 then I would be
saying oh this is uh an opening we've
seen before this is Queen's Gambit one
of the main lines but The Bishop's on C1
Robert so what do you make of this plan
with E4 when you usually see the bishop
on G5 yeah the bishop is less active and
I mean he plays Bishop D2 so he's taking
a slow approach to this game is he
waiting for black to play C5 which of
course is a standard move but the
question becomes what to do next does
black play C4 which is very committal it
gives away the dark squares on the queen
side he starts with A6 but what is the
plan for black that's my essential
question
yeah well normally C4 I actually don't
really like this move in general because
white moves the bishop back and then
immediately to move E4 becomes playable
you know just after a couple of prep
moves so I feel like black holding the
tension is kind of exactly what he wants
to do yeah so status quo is working just
fine for him we could see hanging pawns
at some point a black ever sees the pawn
capture on C5 and he takes back with the
B6 Pawn but right now white is slowly
improving the pieces and Bishop to H6
that hits the pawn E3 don't hang that so
he sticks the Knight on F4 in its path I
feel like gukesh is in familiar
territory based on the speed with which
he's playing
yeah familiar territory or
if he's not I love the speed anyway I
think this is exactly how he needs to
play the game white probably wants to
maybe reposition these Rooks I feel like
The Rook on C1 doesn't need to be there
anymore good slide to D1 it gets off
that diagonal so those moves are are
playable and another thing Robert is
Bishop takes F4 I'm not even sure if
that's a real threat here
yeah Bishop takes F4 and you don't want
to give up that dark Square Bishop when
there's a bishop on C3 and they see D
takes C5 apparently that was a mistake
and I'm wondering if black can just
throw in D4 that pawn E3 is overloaded
first move that comes to my mind D4 Pawn
takes on C5 and then is it gonna get
real messy with Pawn takes E3 things
could just be wild and wacky here I I
don't really know what's going on but
usually based on the type of position we
have here with the Bishops looming for
black I would say that those open Crazy
tactical positions will favor pranav
here it is a moment where we should
remind everybody that we see the eval
bar the players do not so D4 that's a
really committal decision because after
D4 Pawn takes C5 Pawn takes E3 like
we're talking about that Queen could
slide over to B2 for example hitting the
bishop on B7 and the Knight on F6 and
things get wild
yeah no I do not envy uh being one of
these players right now and having to
calculate that and that's what pranav is
actually doing that's why he's down a
minute and a half on the clock Robert he
knows that this is an important Junction
in the game make a wrong decision here
it might just be a bad position that uh
you lose a a slow painful game in yeah
so pranav he senses the moment he's
pausing to try to figure out what move
is acceptable for him D4 being the first
option that comes to mind is there also
Rook takes E3 now that I'm thinking
about the F4 Knight is loose over there
but at the end of those variations black
has to part with the dark Square bishop
and that's something that I would not
want to do
yeah and remember at the end of a lot of
lines the Knight on F6 will just be
hanging so
um both sides have a lot to calculate
but you know what's nice for good cash
is he played the move B4 and while
pronounced calculating on his time so is
gukesh right and Rook takes E3 that move
is played great move sacrificing a rook
for a pawn but you win the Knight on F4
afterwards so if Queen takes E3 Bishop
takes F4 you win the Knight and you also
win The Rook on C1 behind it so Amon in
these positions black looks to be headed
by a pawn but white will have this dark
Square bishop and black will not and
that means the black king on Jade can be
unsafe considering the weak squares the
weak dark squares around it
yeah well said I mean Rook takes E3 even
as a move was well spotted by you and
looks like pranab put in the cursory
calculation where there are still so
many options you could even throw in D4
instead of taking that Knight there's
Queen takes as well I mean Bishop takes
F4 being dubbed a miss right here but I
mean I'm missing what's even going on
here yeah and it could result in a Duff
or black just solid place you know
taking material because black is up at
least will be up by a pawn at the end of
this but I like the dark strip Bishop
for white I have to say that the black
king will be unsafe in many of these
positions so material is one thing but
King safety is another and while the Eva
bar suggests that black is slightly
better this is one of those games that
could go either way
yeah absolutely I I still think like
vtake C5 does make sense to me here
because you want some dark squares
through pieces and the worst would be
for D4 to happen so this is the move
that made sense to me it's played on the
board I'm wondering if black might end
up in a position where he's up a pawn
but loses the dark Square bishop and
that's such a fascinating imbalance
because I don't even know which side I'd
rather have I lean towards White yeah
like Bishop D2 here for example you just
defend the Rook on C1 defend that Rook
on E3 you sort of force some of the
trades even if it costs you the A3 Pawn
I still think white has legitimate
chances because that black king long
term will be unsafe if that Bishop on C3
eventually lands on H6 for example or
that Knight is forced off of F6 the
Knight can't capture in F6 right now
because the C1 Rook is hanging but just
important to point these things out
yeah absolutely I I think in a position
like this bishop to D2 I mean I'll I'll
even pull up the analysis board here and
put Bishop D2 on the board we may see
something to the effect of like you know
Bishop takes here Queen takes A3 Rooks
trade this is the type of position maybe
that you're talking about even though
black has two extra pawns Queen D4
Bishop C3 Bishop H6 I honestly still
think I might take white even though the
engine is doing its best to convince me
that you know we're okay here for black
yeah so that's a position that would be
scary and the players they don't have
the evaluation bar we see this happening
Bishop takes E3 you know Queen trade
being offered if Queen E3 check black
probably wasn't going to lose that and
we see this exact type of position black
objectively better but white has some
good chances against that black king and
black is up two pawns but look at those
pawns A6 isolated D5 isolated if a
bishop sits on D4 that D5 Pawn is
certainly not going anywhere and that
Apon will stop before we can ever get
towards that Queenie Square that's a
great Point yeah Bishop D4 looks like a
fantastic move here I'm thinking okay
Queen D6 can always happen if we need to
defend but also like Bishop B5 if that
ever happens and the bishop trades off
suddenly you start to see blacks
actually wait a minute a lot better
position than I remember
and Buddy played this so well Knight to
E8 just getting the Knight off the
diagonal and Bishop B5 becomes an idea
Knight E6 becomes a way to kick that
bishop and then black can play Pawn to
D4 and I just feel like White's pieces
they're not hitting black quick enough
right you just point out the G6 pawn it
blunts the queen and Bishop and stops
that Knight on G3 it dominates the
Knight that is three squares away
suddenly I'm looking at this and I've
changed my tune I'm on the eval bar
might be right after all but you know
what I think there was a big difference
between Bishop takes E3 and queen takes
E3 the line that I put on the board
first because the bishop took and
suddenly after Queen A3 the bishop on D3
was hanging I didn't like that you know
small deviation and and small difference
between the lines and I don't think the
computer did either which is why renov's
position has been a little bit easier to
play than the one we looked at every
Tempo is essential that's what you're
getting at here and the queen went to E2
because you had to stop Queen E1 check
the queen wants to get up to E5 but even
after Queen E5 black can play F6 so it
may drop the D5 Pawn but is that the end
of the world that's a pretty important
question
yeah no at this point I'm I'm wondering
what's uh what's really happening here
Queen B6 so a check he wants to throw in
which is interesting and I'm wondering
why
yeah the king slides to H1 and the eval
bar didn't exactly approve of it Queen
E5 suddenly is a massive threat uh the
queen is about to infiltrate and go
after the black king so as long as the
white king doesn't get back ranked
checkmated which doesn't seem likely
Black's King is the one in trouble and
by the way black about to be down to a
minute
yeah I was about to say in that position
I was wondering about Bishop to B5 and
there's some cases where after Queen E5
F6 you can give up a pawn and bring your
queen over and it's like yeah I'll give
you one Pawn by force a trade and that
might make my defensive job a lot easier
so even though the engine might be
disliking what pranav is doing he just
might be taking a more human approach to
the defense it's a really good point and
speaking of Pawns Bishop takes A6 can I
just grab that pawn over there because
if the A6 pawns eliminated I think that
most of Black's Advantage is also
eliminated so D4 plus actually shutting
down the bishop but you see the Eva bar
going back to the center yeah I'm come
on I guess a question do you think that
pranav is trying to play it safe to some
extent because he's a three-point lead
that's a good point I I feel like with
these young guys in general but
especially pranav is they're just so
objective you rarely see them playing it
safe like if you're asking me I would
play it safe but I don't think they are
honestly I feel like they're always
trying to maximize and play the position
objectively and Bishop A2 so he goes
back there keeps his Bishop pair alive
he also stops Queen B1 checks if that
dark sweat Bishop were ever to leave the
square uh but black apparently has the
upper hand we're down 35 seconds for
black a lot of time maybe bishop B5
Bishop C4 like sneak the bishop in there
there's a lot of pieces that might get
traded he goes Queen A7 the engine
doesn't exactly approve and now we see
trade on E6 and I guess you could just
play Queen D1 and win that pawn on D4
I was 95. yeah and if Knight E4 we trade
everything and I was just looking at
Queen A2 Queen takes D4 and a sneaky
Queen B1 check winning the game well I
think now we are going to see complete
liquidation the Queens are coming off
and okay good result from print off here
yeah I think that was potentially scary
for both I do think we'll see this
played out just a little bit here if you
know if you've forced me to pick a side
Robert I'm picking white but it is of
course a draw did it
just wait not because he was stressed
about the game is he trying to burn
match clock is it too early to do that
but you know he has experience now in
the speeches Championship formats where
you might want to burn time if you feel
like the quicker time which will favor
you
yeah I mean at that point there's no
risk uh right because I I think uh you
know your draw is not going anywhere so
it's not the case where it's like oh if
I play on to waste the clock I might
lose like nope this is only smart
I guess though you don't want to anger
gukesh I mean he already is trying to
win but you know when they start talking
trash in basketball and you know you
start saying things about Jimmy Butler
and then he just crushes you in the next
game it's one of those moments where
maybe you know just play the game you
have a lead you're playing well there's
no need for antics off uh side of that
yeah that's that's a good point I wonder
if that is playing into anyone's mind
right here because honestly I would
probably be thinking about stuff like
that yeah and I'm thinking about this
position here I'm on the Double C pawns
for black the bishop pair for black so
that's been the theme of this match
gukesh no matter if you play C5 or E5 he
gets a pair of Bishops but his Pawn
structure is compromised yep a theme for
both players and both players are happy
to go into these positions so that's why
I think we'll just get such an
interesting Dynamic match both sides are
happy to take their respective you know
advantages or pluses and try to make
them work at the end of the day it's
just about proving what you have is is
better than what your opponent has that
the engine is going to say hey it's
equal but it's up to these players to
show why and queen F7 hits the Knight on
C4 what black wants to do is get an open
Bishop that C8 Bishop needs to get some
space Maybe A5 right now with Bishop A6
to follow I like that idea yeah and you
could still play it takes takes and
still play A5 yep that's a good one
and how does white meet this because
Bishop A6 you could play B3 but now that
Bishop on H4 feels like it's operating
on the wrong side of the board so it
goes back to G3 to hit C7 I can
appreciate that but it feels like
Black's play is much more natural at the
moment
definitely yeah um the the C Pawn by the
way is actually a really really
important Pawn right like if you if you
lose that thing then everything kind of
falls apart also Rook E2 I think then
you can really consider a move like B5
with everything lined up on the diagonal
so Rook E3 was played specifically I
think because of that and now B5 from
black anyway and White's Pawn structure
in the center it looks very promising
you have two Pawns in the center and
black is zero on D4 and E4 but they're
also going to be targeted by Black's
pieces and after a takes B5 if C takes
B5 is there Knight takes A5 did gukesh
maybe Rush that B Pawn push because now
his doubled C pawns don't look very
appealing
yeah that's right he has to take with
the bishop here which maybe he doesn't
want but another thing to remember is
he's played with these double isolated
pawns before he clearly wants the
Bishops doesn't care about the structure
so much and while C7 is hanging A4 is
about to happen and that will really
undermine that Knight on C4 so The Rook
comes to C1 to defend that Knight give
it one more piece to protect it and now
I think for black I would think about
Knight B6 just piling up more pressure
on the Knight and C4 or Knight to f8
because sometimes you play Knight f8 96
rook d8 and go after the White Center
yep that's a nice uh maneuver there it
does feel like the candidate moves for
black are a little bit more inspiring
easier to play more threats whereas for
white you just kind of have a nice
position right you know black can
improve his position and white is like
it's already good yeah and he white has
to retreat out of the pin so A4 for
black makes perfect sense to me if white
plays Knight takes B6 and black plays C
takes B6 Black's Pawn structure becomes
healthy all of a sudden and then the
Bishops will show their might yeah that
looks very very good for black at least
a nice achievement you know whether or
not the engine says hey this is you know
much much better for you this is exactly
what black wanted Bishop pair uh pass
Pawn by the way protected pass Pawn on
the B file might not look like it but
that is the case Bishop takes A4 the
engine says no
why is that I'm not sure maybe because
Queen B2 hits B6 through that bishop and
C5 D5 what is happening because these
positions are really hard to assess we
have the eve of our saying white is
slightly better but one inaccuracy and
suddenly black is much better because we
will see a protected past Pawn on D5 if
white chooses that move but black will
have two past pawns on the B and C files
with Bishop supporting them yeah these
are you know a nightmare to try to
follow with the the engine eval it just
doesn't make sense uh I would
instinctively look at this and think if
there's two pawns down the center board
two pawns on the wing and one side as
the two Bishops I probably prefer black
me too and Bishop D6 played to avoid
those pawns rolling up the board so he
tries to go for the C5 Pawn directly and
liquidation that could lead to equality
but it also makes White's life much
easier
yep so taking is obviously the intention
now uh Rook C8 is nice and simple
I would probably play that move I'm
trying to figure out what he's thinking
about here and
what other candidates come to mind for
black
um trying to think of something a little
more aggressive like moving the bishop
to get Rook A2 but ultimately we need to
handle the C Pawn right now taking of
course a threatening The Rook so you
wouldn't be able to pick up the bishop
but takes Queen takes D4 and if these
Bishops trade by the way the dark Square
Bishops I'm immediately liking White's
chances
yeah white could have an upper hand in
these positions to be E5 that could go
up to the black king there's a rook on
E3 that's a rook lift it was a defensive
move earlier when it was under attack
but E5 trade on E5 get that Rook over to
the G3 square that black king could be
in trouble because look at that Bishop
on B4 it cannot help in any defense on
the right half of the board yeah exactly
it's blocked by its own pawn and it's
just kind of stuck there for the moment
especially with the c pawn attack White
playing E5 if that gets uh captured you
know Rook slides to G3 as you just
mentioned there could be an attack for
white here uh Against All Odds so these
Bishops yes they're looking good but
they're almost looking uh just optically
good I'm not sure they're actually doing
anything from where they stand yeah and
this the fact that this Pawn can go to
C4 if you could get C4 C3 and you're
feeling super happy as black but you're
stopped in your tracks you're not
getting anywhere so I think kukesh has
the more difficult tasks remember
earlier uh we were saying the candid
moves felt easier for black now they
just feel easier for what E5 as a
starting point how does black even
respond to that pawn push I think you
have to take but I mean at this point
Bishop takes E5 and uh things are lining
up for Rook G3
yeah for sure and you see print off
pause I love that he's saying I can take
on E5 with the bishop if I were playing
bullet I would do that without
hesitation but he's trying to work out
the tactics here that Bishop on D6 is
under attack but Knight takes E5 hits
the queen and the bishop on D6 looks
like it's running out of squares but
maybe there is a way to keep it defended
yeah exactly and Knight takes on
um E5 suddenly that might put the
question to the queen and you know just
those simple uh moves gaining time can
be enough to uh to shift an attack in
your favor so he's spending time he's
looking I still think Bishop E5 makes
the most sense 95 I'm looking at Queen
F6 but there's Queen A2 check I just saw
it that is a wow big threat from White
so if you have to stay on the light
squares and play Queen E6 then I love
Knight E5 right because then there's
Knight C4 yeah he decides against it
maybe there was a queen D5 or queen E6
as we were mentioning that kept black in
the game but he takes with the bishop
185 can hardly complain about it it
seems like it's a Miss uh we both backed
that up Knight takes E5 did look like
there were tactics available and Bishop
C6 is a great response from gookesh his
Bishops were in no man's land now you
can take on F3 at some moment but G7
remains a problem for white excuse me
for black to deal with
yeah the bishop on C6 I have to you know
give some credit because finally I think
that Bishop has reached maybe the best
diagonal uh best spot it could it could
be on Rook sliding over to G3 though and
if you have to play G6 to deal with that
pawn Robert oh man I do not envy your
defensive task we're just talking about
a great lights a dark script Bishop in
the previous game if you hit play G6
that Bishop on E5 will Thrive and so
Knight G5 we live where's James candy
when you need it oh my goodness yeah you
really dropped a bar there yeah Rook G3
I think that all of a sudden drop more
than bars he'd be dropping hammers on
blacks defenses and that Bishop on B4 it
has not been the game but you should
watch out for Bishop D2 if you're not
looking out there could be a I was like
called a fork is that a fork or a skewer
what do you call that I guess it's a
fork but it's one of the most Close
Quarters that you could ever ever have
really
um but yeah you're right at this point
black is looking to involve that Bishop
in the game maybe at the cost of the
pawn because he's gonna quickly realize
look the defensive task with that thing
sitting there doing absolutely nothing
is not gonna happen Queen B3 or queen A2
the moves that previously were nearly
winning on the spot are now met by
Bishop D5 such a great defensive move he
went Knight F3 because in addition to
Bishop B2 Rook D2 was a very dangerous
threat going after the F2 Pawn so he
just slides back with his Knight but you
could tell White's lesson was Knight G5
and then back to F3 that's a bad sign or
at least it's a good sign for black as
he tries to defend his King I'm looking
at Bishop C3 and I really like the the
move in general because it gets rid of
these Bishops it also clears the E5
Square so I don't know what these
players are thinking in their heads it'd
be so interesting to know like are they
thinking that they're better playing for
a win or they don't know what's going on
they're just playing I I think prinoff
knows that he's been better I saw his
face earlier when the pawn capture on E5
but at this moment this is a critical
one because black now has an even
material but the king feels a little bit
less safe so do you start trading off
pieces for good cash that's the big
question
right and there could be some really
clever sacrifices here I was almost
thinking of like you know Queen C5 of
course there's Rook D1 King H2 and you
have to be super careful that you don't
get hit with Queen F4 Bishop takes F3
and some Checkmate ideas down the line
all sorts of tactical ideas here and go
catch down under 26 he blocks with his
Rook I mean that doesn't look right
there yeah remember it's pinned so 95
rookie five these are all moves to be
very very careful of
and Rook E6 hitting the bishop what's
next if the bishop just drops back to A8
oh that looks scary moves
yeah because yeah this one you just move
the king and you're kind of okay there
actually
so Rook to Eva Queen F7 that we're gonna
D5 is protected thanks to the bishop run
A8 there's too much tension there in the
center I don't know what's happening
yeah takes on D5 Bishop D5 actually
loses he plays King H2 how does he have
time for that well black doesn't have a
move does he because Rook D7 is rookie
eight check so where does black go five
seconds he was King h8 maybe that's the
best move but white suddenly on the
offensive
yeah now rookie 8 Queen E4 and Rook h8
that's a tactic to watch out for oh but
you don't have rookie because there's a
rook on d8 that's why he didn't trade
Brooks
so sneaky
Rook takes on d8 why didn't he play that
one he would have won the pawn but I
guess it would have been a draw after
Bishop takes Knight but now black is
better all of a sudden you have to be
very careful you know when the
trajectory of the game turns and you're
a better all game he's worse there's a
pass Pawn running up the board Yep this
is completely turned on its head however
you know I still think anyone could win
it's about who holds their their nerves
better in the time scramble and he went
Rook to C3 I thought he had Rook to the
D file instead but he wants to drag the
white king over bring the black king in
three seconds per side so to be very
careful not to walk into a losing King
opponent game Knight D5 was giving me
some scary moments there we might see
rook d8 and king C3 plays for some
result here still well white is
obviously up a pawn but the King was cut
off for a moment but now the king is
coming back this should be a draw it's a
theoretical draw but look at the clocks
mistakes happen when you're down to your
dwindling seconds absolutely
he's trying to create something here
with that move H4
and the pawns are split now which should
ease Black's task and the white king is
cut off
yep and actually yeah Rook A4 I think
helps out the most
now things should be relatively easy you
keep the king cut off and then you play
Rook A4 whenever needed
it's a great defense from gukesh
throughout the latter part of this game
but pranav had his chances I love the
way buddy is playing he's been super
consistent throughout he's missed some
Knockouts you know there of course are
going to be inaccuracies but he's
playing such great chess overall he
really is
and here Rook G1 check King F4 you have
to be careful at all moments here King
F4 Rook to E4
he's making some progress but still good
defense
yeah there's not much progress to be had
at The Rook G1 check you have to go King
F4 back in The Rook H1 all right now you
trade on G5 this is going to be a draw a
hard fought game between these two
competitors
yeah and you know we we talked about how
close this match was gonna be you're
starting to see these games can swing to
either size really competitive but
Bernard has that buffer of points that
he earned at the beginning of this five
minute segment so he's happy to just go
Toe to Toe from here on out yeah drawing
the rest of the way means a match
Victory and at some point gukesh will
get a win and that's going to be I think
the biggest moment of the match for me
is how pranav responds to that because
you know when uh your David versus
Goliath and Goliath you think is going
to just win but at some moment you don't
want to Unleash the Beast so to speak
and for gukesh in this game I think I
like the opening for white
yeah and I I also
I I want to ask like statisticians of
the world when has a first seed in a
championship like this not one a single
game this far into the match because
that's the case right now right it's his
points have come from all draws yeah
we'll have to dive into the Treasure
Trove of data that we've accumulated
over the years of the speed test
championship and you think about the
number one seeds in the main speeches
Championship Magnus Carlson nikara
Nakamura they usually win games except
in Norway chess where of course everyone
Simon Magnus did not win a colossal game
there uh but that's right look at this
position speaking of winning games I
already love White's position G4 Knight
g3 at the right moment maybe start with
Queen C2 go right after this E4 Pawn
that pawn is sticking out like a sore
thumb it is yeah it's this unusual plan
of G4 and Knight G3 and G4 does a few
things it threatens to kick the night
out of F6 which is a Defender it
prevents Bishop F5 which would be
another Defender and it adds Knight G3
which is another attacker so T4 is like
the hero move yeah and queen T2 first
because Knight E5 came with a Tempo
against the C4 pawn and Knight D3 check
or Knight F3 check so Queen still hits
the pawn directly black may have to spin
to turnplate Queen E7 and then there
will be no Knight E5 follow-up because
E4 will drop I think this is great
Precision from gukesh and I'm looking at
this position I'm looking at the clocks
I'm just looking at E4 Pawn I really
believe that gookash has the upper upper
hand and I was gonna say his plan is
quite simple
yeah and there's also situations Robert
where you can allow Knight D3 move your
king and say yep that's okay uh we don't
care E4 Pawn is falling no matter what
so I'm actually wondering how pranav can
just get something going like something
in the way of counter play Queen E7 you
pretty much have to start with but we
knew G4 was happening I do not like this
position for black not one bit and
Knight E5 the idea that you're
mentioning C is black brother gonna go
after the C4 Pawn I would think yes and
if Knight G3 then I were already there
G5 would trap the knight in F6 so he
plays H6 himself to stop G5 for the time
being but after Knight G3 E4 just drops
exactly and we see B5 thrown up by
pranavan I mean understandable I was
actually wondering was there like a
knight F5 that should have been played
or just Knight takes E4 because he took
and this kind of gives black what he
wants right like this is turning into a
benko type position you're a hundred
percent correct let's bring up an
analysis board because a man wanted to
throw in a Tempo gaining move with
Knight to F5 so at that moment Knight F5
hits the queen and then you could take
on B5 with the Knight and then D6 will
fall next so the knights just from both
sides would hit and win that pawn
exactly I think he was so focused on
winning the E Pawn that he was like no
I'm gonna choose the path forward that
wins the e-pawn where I think he could
have pivoted from his plan and now look
at this position black all of a sudden
has so many chances that he probably
shouldn't have had at all yeah and
Knight F5 takes D6 as possible the
Knight on B5 is a bit pinned to The Rook
on F1 but after Knight F takes D6 now
your Knights are stuck defending each
other and it's uncomfortable as black
will start attacking on the king side
watch out for an H5 after Knight F5
takes D6 rookie five then H5 and it's
the white king that will be in danger
yeah that's right it's this Jeep on it
the pawn was back on G3 of course none
of this would even happen so we wouldn't
be here but the fact the pawns on G4 it
can be used against you and he takes
with the B night Robert what do you
think of that decision obviously giving
up the Rook but he would rather play a
position where he's down material in
terms of you know the larger sense of
the word but he just has a very solid
position no weaknesses yeah if I didn't
have the eval bar to look at I would
never put a question mark on that move
it looks very natural it looks like it
helps your king remain safe your Knights
are in contact with one another and
Brook to B8 so pranav is down two full
pawns here and I think he wants to plant
that Bishop on D3 and then claim
compensation around that Banco style
activity over on the queen said not to
mention the D5 Pawn is hanging it is and
I'm starting to wonder on the previous
turn Bishop D3 and Van Rook B8 was
probably something that should have been
played because as white I love the
decision great heads up move Knight
takes on e4 yes take the Rook Knight
takes E4 by the way got a brilliancy
awarded to it and I fully agree not
everyone feels comfortable just giving
up material like that but Robert I think
it's an amazing decision and Bishop D3
missed by pranov now he's paying for it
yeah love that decision there it looks
like White's Queen side pawns are about
to fall one by one A2 and then B2 next
but there's that pawn on D5 that well
now it's on D6 that is a healthy pass
Pawn the Knight on F5 if you kick it out
with G6 the squares around your king
feel vulnerable and the Knight jumps
into E7 with check so unless black can
keep this Knight on D7 to blockade that
D6 Pawn I think that he will be in
trouble and we see an advantage for
white
yeah and Rook takes B2 it's a weird
position because Black's kind of
achieved everyone's the chess player's
dream right two ropes on the second rank
is black but you you're not threatening
anything on F2 so what's the next step
all I know is don't move your knight
unless it's the F6 because Knight G6
check was going to be a nasty move so
like for example Bishop D5 here don't
take that Bishop because that Knight G6
check wins the queen
oh that's a great tactic yeah very
tricky Queen on f8 King on h8 and G5 he
wants that Knight to move clearly and
now he wants Anastasia's mate right
there's just gonna be a make down the H
file especially if you can bring your
Rook into the action so be very very
careful if you are pranav here I
actually think that this one is hard to
defend
yeah very hard to defend
Bishop to E4 is that an idea here
because then you've got your mate and
there's no Knight H7 in the event of uh
of that move next so Bishop B4 looks
really strong that is brilliant because
if you start with Queen H4 check and the
Knight goes to H7 Bishop E4 will be met
by Pawn to G6 that will be available to
Black to help him Escape so Bishop E4 is
super precise and it's a knockout and
cash has two minutes to find it I think
he will
surely yeah no And even if he doesn't I
I do think he's gonna get this game but
this is the moment where you know
Precision is required and I think he's
gonna spot it and I also don't see any
move that that black can play after that
maybe bishop E4 Rook E6 and Knight H5
trying to play Rook H6 I mean I'm just
trying to survive here you've found a
way to survive that's actually a really
nice line and maybe the only line that
keeps black in the game but I have to
say thus far I've really liked the way
gukesh has played this one he's down
three points this has been oh look at
that Bishop E4 found a very complete
game from him and that move deserves
some exclamation points there are two of
them it's a brilliant Choice good find
by umon and great play from gukesh
totally deserved there yeah this is a
wicked move her novel not be happy to
see this one on the board I think Rook
D6 might be one of the only moves
because G6 and and taking there is just
silly but I actually didn't consider it
or didn't even see Knight G8
wow okay so
oh so check good night H6 what an idea
what defense there by pranav she he
actually didn't seem phase but he's like
oh nice brilliancy I've raised you a
strong defensive move
and queen F5 played Knight goes back to
F6
yeah your idea by the way G6 Knight G6
was uh was available there so oh wow wow
this is gorgeous Queen G5 to F5 to F4
and now Knight G8 doesn't work as Knight
G6 check at a minimum you win the queen
and queen H4 check is a threat so he
goes Knight to H5 but Knight G6 check I
guess you have King G8 and somehow you
fight on
this is an incredible line and I mean
both guys are going Toe to Toe it is as
impressive to see the attacking move as
it is the defensive moves here and queen
HR so G6 he'll take on g65 with the
bishop because you can't take with the
pawn so finally we get this position
that you expected earlier and now white
has 200 pieces and a pawn for a rook
plus a safer King this is wow great
position for gukeshi I did not expect us
Robert to get here the way we did I
didn't factor in those uh beautiful
beautiful moves on both sides but yeah I
mean you called it here white has to win
this game I'm just gonna go out and say
it if you don't convert a game like this
with the match score the way it is uh as
gukesh then I think you have a lot to be
concerned about yeah 30 seconds on this
clock you should be concerned about that
as well I would play Rook C1 and try to
play Queen C8 back rank Checkmate and
white has a safe King The King on G1 is
perfectly defended over there so let's
just coordinate our pieces he plays
Knight C6 a move I don't love but I
guess the black queen cannot leave the
back rank that's right and I I feel like
white just needs to like Bishop G2 sort
of like recoup here just bring everyone
back to base uh I I think that's the
secure way to do things in f8 yep there
we go
okay I totally forgot you know what's
funny about those ends of games people
like oh I blundered mate in one it's
like no actually go cash outplayed print
off all games so I ended up with
checkmated one but that was a very
brilliant game from gokash now you
really feel like he's back in the match
totally and you know the fact of the
matter is that's that's absolutely
correct he is back in this match that is
a big step forward for him and I think
uh going forward here gotta hand go cash
a lot of credit he might have heard me I
said I'm pretty sure that he's gonna
start winning a game did he hear me talk
about that stat about a number one seed
not winning again I might have rallied
the uh the demon inside him hey UMBC a
chess school but also a basketball
school upstanding the one seed and Lucas
does not want to be upset as the one
seed and this position has become very
trendy at the highest levels the bishop
went to G4 the D4 Pawn feels a bit
vulnerable but for now white has enough
Defenders there and it's pranab with the
first thing and man it's usually a bad
sign when you get into an opening that
is well known at the highest levels and
then you start thinking but both players
seem to be unfamiliar now on move 10.
yeah a lot of times uh when you see a
very strong well-prepared player uh
thinking early on it's not that they
haven't seen it before and they don't
know what to do it's that they have seen
it before and they have so many options
of how they want to proceed and they're
just kind of deciding what game do I
want to play you know do I want to play
the line where I give the bishop pair up
but I damage the pawn structure do what
you know basically sizing up your
opponent how the match has been going so
a lot of important decisions to make
early on and I talk about those double
pawns Robert Bishop takes Knight white
is actually ready to a lot of the time
play Pawn takes on F3 just to dislodge
the Knight on e4 very counter-intuitive
it's right though you force the Knight
out of E4 if we see more trades Knight
takes either B takes you the only Alps
white you get to establish a protected
Pawn on D4 all of a sudden and the whole
point of G takes F3 is that the queen
took an F3 the D4 Pawn is loose so
that's why you're encouraged or you kind
of have to take on F3 with the pawn in
these types of positions so Mukesh is
he's in for a thing now F6 is a very
thematic move in these types of
positions just trying to Chisel at the
center open the F line I'm wondering if
it's the correct move right now
yeah if F6 Pawn takes you also can't
really take with the queen because of
the D5 Pawn so lots to consider and he's
basically doing your move but going one
step further saying okay I'll go at five
if you want to take me it's the same as
F6 but if you don't capture me and guess
what you have to decide right now you
don't take me the Knight on e4 is there
to stay yeah 94 is there to stay this
pin on the Knight and F3 also seems like
it's gonna remain look at this move
Knight E2 you called it Bishop F3 gf3
white is not afraid of that and the F4
Square feels very juicy so is black
gonna play G5 so he doesn't have to give
up his bishop and he controls F4
wow G5 would be quite the move I mean
very very committal King is wide open
instead he plays Bishop F3 honestly I
think this is exactly what uh prenov
wanted to see however he is headed to an
important square and we talk about how
to blockade pass bonds protected pass
bonds Robert the Knight is the best
piece so you can see what he's up to
here yeah and after F4 that Knight can
go up to E6 the block hit it can also
jump into F3 with check and over to H4
and because prernoff didn't want that he
was King G2 but that's a big mistake and
if the bar is dropping that much there's
a tactic I think it must be the pawn to
F4 for black
yeah I think at this point you know you
just because you know it's there It's
gotta be that move um the thing about F4
is that you're ready to sack a rook for
a piece and then take on D4 and after
you take a D4 and you're hitting the
bishop you're you've got more than
enough compensation so this could get
bad for putting up real quick and
actually you can even invert the move
order I like the exchange stack but
you're gonna just take on D4 as well
because that Bishop on E3 is overloaded
uh I was first attempted to The Exchange
SEC but now that we're here and I you
know the eval bar is just screaming for
the black position oh this King on G2 is
oh it's toasted I don't know how it how
you survive here honestly
um I mean one thing that's maybe coming
to mind is like take on D4 and go back
to E3 in a weird weird way to proceed
can you play Rook takes F3 Bishop G5
Queen G5 check the King goes out to F3
you win a rook but do you get checkmated
is my big question
well the position for uh White is so bad
that it's like uh I'll take the extra
broke and find out the answer yeah
that's true at least you'll have
material for your problems what does
that yasu like to say like you like at
least you die with a full stomach
yeah exactly he also likes to use the
line you know
um well the thing is Robert my needs are
great
he likes to use that one and there's
that one about court schnoy he'd be
willing to walk through the Gobi desert
to you know to take the material uh so
Rook takes F3 I mean that looks
fascinating but can black you know you
said in exchange second black just play
Knight E6 here
please I'd love to see it let's let's
walk through the desert together yeah
but he goes Rook takes F3 so here we go
I think that if you know white has any
chance you have to take the material but
good cash likely has played this out the
Checkmate yeah and whoa it is made and
it's gonna be in the flashiest way
possible double X Glam and that was the
best and probably almost only move
Robert it's Fourth Checkmate and okay
question for you now was that a mistake
for pranav to resign he was dead lost it
was force made but look at the match
clock there's two minutes and change
left in this time segment Amman he could
have let that time elapse head into
quicker time Patrols
yeah very interesting because honestly
with the momentum I'm gonna go with you
and say it mistake uh let the time run
out you know a lot of games been shipped
there it's not to every player's
preference you know it depends what kind
of competitor you are but this is
clearly shifting into Cash's favor if he
ends with another win here guess what we
have a tide match Robert and I think
yeah Escape that five minute portion
with the lead was the right way to go
yeah and all of a sudden gokash two wins
in a row to his name he must be feeling
good about his chances and it's what
we're discussing do you you have you
unleashed the beast so he got that first
taste of Victory and now he wants more
he's hungry and now he has the bishop
pair I like White's position I think
this is an opening Advantage for sure
you have an unopposed Bishop pair your
Pawn structure is healthy you've done
really nothing at all and you have a
slight Edge
that was such an incredible finish Rook
takes F2 it's like you know I might sit
there and be like yeah I know it's
winning it's got to be winning for black
but he didn't he can't sit there when
he's calculating Robert you can't make
mistakes being down the road he
calculated that out Rook takes F2 is
just such a stunner of a move uh so he's
got to be feeling himself right now you
know riding that adrenaline high for
sure and cash he's down on the clock in
this game here pranav is playing much
more quickly but I'm looking at this
position and I just don't see any risk
in White's Camp it just casted kingside
very safe over there bishwan E5 looks
nice and for black if you castle
kingside at some point will white play
F4 and maybe F5 and just start throwing
pieces at the black king
yeah I mean you definitely can't Castle
Queen side so if you're not castling
King side soon I'm with you like I'm
wondering how you even proceed so he
goes Knight D7 his Bishop takes G6
available I guess not because of Knight
takes E5 but now Bishop G6 is a threat
that's right Bishop takes wean takes and
queen takes E6 so he goes F5 to deal
with that but man if this position opens
up it is gonna be a disaster for black
yeah I'm already looking it's a Carlsbad
structure we've been so I've been so
focused excuse me on the bishop pair can
you play A3 B4 B5 it used to have a
strategic Plus
yeah the queen on A5 is not supposed to
be there right this is a strange
position because okay now the queen goes
back but you can't stop B5 you play A6
how slow is Black's position you still
haven't castled yeah and I'm not trading
on H4 he plays Bishop H2 because that
would allow the queen into H4 with a
knight G5 to follow maybe some
sacrifices the bishop on H4 is actually
in Black's way you want that open Line
you want to start attacking but there is
no attack that I see this just looks
like another one-sided game for gukesh
if he wins a third game in a row he'll
even up the match score and this is the
last game in the longest time Patrol the
match clock is at zeros which means we
finish this game and then we go to the
three minute plus one second increment
time Patrol
absolutely this looks close to you know
definitely much worse but almost
teetering on lost if you don't make the
right decisions Here pawn takes on C6
Pawn takes Bishop A6 you're already
losing that rook and if you take with
the Rook on C6 I mean I'm just moving my
queen and good luck defending the d-pawn
the b-pawn
do not like I'm with you I know you
didn't want to use such strong language
you kind of held yourself back but
strategically I think you know we call
these positions about losing for black
like this position you're just hanging
on by a thread and it's going to be hard
to continue doing that pranav is down on
the clock he is down facing a bishop
pair his King is in the center even if
he castles his Pawn structure will be
compromised or lose an exchange Gucci
looks ready to win his third straight
game
he does uh he's up now approaching a
minute on the clock knight ever returns
to F6 which I was about to say like it
looks like it almost has to first of all
Bishop A6 is winning material Bishop can
slide into E5 as well at this point I'm
collecting material with Bishop A6
and he does and I like the way that
pranav has done this don't take this
Rook on C7 I don't think you should
because black wants some play on the
dark squares
it's still winning for white but I
thought that he could have played like a
rook B1 kind of like a waiting move
right because that Rook wasn't going
anywhere yeah and it may have like just
resulted in the same position because
eventually you probably would have to
take the Rook but yeah it's often the
case where black almost wants you to
take and look he's gonna be going for
last ditch effort stuff now ig5 trying
to get Knight takes H3 G5 G4 but
honestly Robert I mean it's I'm not
convinced even looking at my own arrows
here yeah and the more we see this
position the more I'm like yeah just
take the Rook that was the good call
from good cash and he's thinking now he
has many good options does black have
some
semblance of attack is there anything
that pranav can do to spice this game up
I'm I've desperately looking honestly
and I don't see anything night
I mean like F4 the G6 Pawn hangs G5 the
F5 Pawn hangs I'm trying to find it here
oh I see something Knight G4 and if you
take Queen H2 check oh you're you're
sick
we have to have to put that on the
analysis for it that was a threat with
the Rook on F1 that's why he went Rook
F1 to C1
and of course King F1 will be played but
this is what the fans want to see
wow yeah that but but that actually goes
to show that Rook F1 moving out the way
was critically important right yeah
Knight G4 was a legitimate threat to win
on the spot in that game
okay so he moves his Rook out the way
Knight G4 just gives away another piece
so this looks like Knight B5 is a threat
for white you're just barreling down the
C file I think that gukesh is taking
this one I I mean what can black Do Your
Castle you just lose more material you
don't Castle your king is probably going
to be in trouble and I just don't see
any attack for black yeah Not only was
that a really cool idea but so much
credit to kukesh for spotting it I
honestly probably would have played Rook
a to B1 and just try to go Rook B7 in
that position and the fact that
something so nasty was looming in the
air did not occur to me
and well for pranav he has nothing nasty
anymore the only thing that's nasty
unfortunately this is his position and
I'm looking at the moment and I'm
wondering if does Knight to B5 work or
um
are you just grabbing the C6 Pawn yeah
that looks very very convincing
um
trying to find a way for it to work and
wow he just goes straight for it
wow it's a brilliant move but isn't he
giving up material Knight takes D5 Queen
takes C6 I guess he has two pawns for a
piece and that light Square diagonal
seems to be a problem for black I think
he just ties every piece down because
The Bishop's gonna come back to C4 the
Rooks just invade and the Knights are so
clumsy like if you have to take and play
Knight C7 I think Bishop C4 Rook B1 Rook
B7 and every single piece of black
position is tied down and can't move
it's true and if you play Knight d8
hitting the Rook on C6 you can play
Bishop C4 actually because you get both
of the knights in a row thanks to the
check on D5 yep
yep Bishop C4 or Rook B1 here look like
the moves and this is just really Savvy
conversion uh technique by Gucci and
everyone here a thing or two he did not
want to play that position you know with
the Queens on the board any longer than
he had to
I feel like the teacher's pet I had a
front row seat to that lesson that was
very instructive Knight takes D5 was not
a move I was considering I was thinking
about going the night in the other
direction but he gives up material to
get some and Rook B7 check a huge threat
if black plays Rook to D7 you can maybe
take on D5 and then play Rook B7 check
and you win another Pawn on A7 so right
now white has what is it two pawns and a
rook for two minor pieces but the
knights are clumsy yep five more
pressure that King by the way cannot
wait to leave that light score diagonal
but there's just no time
no there isn't and there's no time on
pronounced clock either he drops down to
about 35 seconds at the moment and his
Knights are stumbling and you can maybe
even play Rook B7 right now and just pin
everything that's right yeah Rook B7
looks like the move
Brooke to E5 I mean everything works I
mean I at this point you're just kind of
picking and choosing G3 later on will
just be such a strong move so
um just we'll just watch him convert
this because he's honestly just a
beautiful game so far
King E7 D5 seems to win a piece the
knights are kicked away from the defense
of one another and that should finally
be that yep I don't think we'll see uh
him playing on much past this yeah D5
should be it Knight takes D5 we just
create The Rook first and then Bishop
takes
oh
out check
so strong
yeah he just forces that Rook to capture
then you win the Knight on C7 you keep
trading pieces and I think doesn't D
take C7 get you a new Queen let's check
by the way yeah it's a good point that
is check uh that's probably gonna do it
1966 and queen and fortunately you have
that escape Square so nothing to worry
about wow what a performance by gukesh
at the end of that five minute segment
Robert this is a tide match and
completely you know turned this whole
match on its head from what we saw at
the beginning of the five minute portion
yeah it's a tied match indeed and it's
four and a half four and a half but it
started in pranav's favorite he went out
to a lightning hot start and then
suddenly three wins in a row for gukesh
to end that time segment the players
will get a break and I think it could
come at a better time for pranav he
needs to rest a little bit and then
start that three minute second fresh he
does yeah no it's it's absolutely
necessary here Robert I think the fans
are truly getting you know their uh the
best match possible out of this we saw
him fall behind early but good cash
brought it right back showing everyone
why he is the number one seed and why
you can't count him out that early it's
a momentum type of game Robert and we
saw the momentum for both players on
display
we did and when you see four and a half
four and have a tie score you think oh
they were just even throughout no there
were a bunch of wins for pranav then
three wins right there for good cash so
both players have been swinging and that
brings us to an important question one
that we are getting involved the game
the community involved with because uh
this week we asked our Discord Community
to discuss a controversial Topic in
chess
should the draw offer be banned we
debate chess topics like this every week
in the chess.com Discord server Amman
I've been very vocal of it about this I
think the draw offer should be banned
what do you think
so I actually don't know about your
vocal stance on the the draw effort you
say you've been vocal about it I
actually didn't know that so can I put
you on the spot first maybe everyone's
like oh Robert keeps talking about this
I actually haven't heard it so why
should it be bad
well I just think that it encourages
people to bail out even in critical
moments where the result is up in the
air think about your own tournament
games I know when I was younger someone
would offer me a draw at a complex
position and I would be tempted to take
it but that deprives Spectators of the
excitement of those games and players
they do what's best for them so I'm not
even blaming individuals if they think
the Berlin draws for them and they force
that repetition you can't stop that
that's in the rules of Chess maybe
organizers can stop inviting them as Sam
Shanklin posted about on Facebook he
thought that people who do that kind of
stuff you know shouldn't be the people
getting invited tournaments but draw
offers are different like you are in the
middle of a complex game and you're like
let's just end this one and we both get
half a point that's not something you
see in most other games or Sports
yeah that's I think that comparison at
the end is immediately where my mind
goes is the way I would even approach
the question is like trying to reference
another sport you know I watch a lot of
sports and I'm trying to think like at
what point can everyone just say
all right uh see you guys next week
um you know it can't really happen like
that so to be honest with you I've never
thought about this question until it's
literally been in front of me right now
but I would say that
I lean towards yes and I would probably
need to be convinced otherwise because
there's just too much obvious compelling
evidence that why are we allowed to just
stand up and walk away from an ongoing
game an important struggle but I also uh
I don't know if I would be a GM today if
I didn't offer a few draws Robert so uh
not gonna say more on the topic
it's the ultimate GM Bella when we're in
trouble over the board and it's a low
rate of player you offer a drawn hope
that they accept but exactly do get
involved in this discussion it's an
important one and I think that it's an
interesting one so uh please get
involved with our Discord community and
for now Amanda will take a break but
when we return what's not up for
discussion is it will be an exciting
continuation of the match between good
cash and pranav here in the 2023 Junior
speed Chess Championship
thank you
did you know you can add Emoji to your
online games and Analysis boards simply
click on the Emoji palette icon select
your emoji and left click on the board
you can choose from a host of notations
animations emoticons and even your
favorite chess personalities
emoticons it will fade away after a few
seconds
however notations and special animations
remain on the board until they are
cleared to clear them simply left click
on the Emoji or hit the clear all button
at the bottom of the palette
try them all on chess.com
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
here we see kukesh the number 13 rated
player in the live classical ratings in
the entire world and the winner of the
last three games in the five minute plus
one second increment time segment here
in his jscc match against pranav Amanda
was not a pretty start for him he was
down by three points now the match is
tied but he must be feeling pretty good
about himself is gukesh absolutely I
mean the the match score tied up there
in the five minute portion I think going
into this match if you just said um yeah
pronounce will be tied with good cash
after the five minute portion
you say oh that's great you know
congrats to him he probably had a good
first segment but then you realize how
we got here and it tells a much
different story so despite this being
objectively good results so far for
pranav but you have to remember Robert
how we got here and I don't think that's
the case at all I think he's going to be
feeling the pressure going into the
three minute
yeah and four and a half four and a half
sounds like a great result for pronoun
before the matches You're Gonna Leave
the longest time to go tied with gukesh
please sign me up I'll take that but
it's not going to feel so good given
what's happened in recent games and
speaking of not so good there are a lot
of Double C Pawns in this position there
are is that good for one side or are
both sides unhappy about it
well maybe in this position I would say
the one thing I don't love is that the C
Pawn you know can be coaxed to move to
the C5 square and you know that seems
completely okay for for white because
the bishop gets locked in but the pawns
that about dark squares black can always
Break Free with B6 so long term it's
like I think we're probably just equal
here but I don't know if if anyone
really has a a pull here
yeah one of the big questions is what
pieces do the sides want traded yeah
kukesh is playing very quickly he
brought his A8 Rook to d8 I would have
thought of bringing my h8 Rook to d8
because I have to play Knight f8 as a
follow-up so these sort of quick moves
can be imprecise sometimes if you're not
looking out for your next idea where is
the Knight on D7 go back to B8 nobody
wants to go there yeah that's that's
really
ugly looking you know what might happen
some crazy kind of idea is Knight B8
takes and you have to be so careful that
C5 Bishop E3 and if white just had one
more move Knight D2 to B3 you defend
that pawn and then that Bishop test web
robber he's not playing chess for the
rest of the game
and guess what Knight B8 runs right to
Knight takes E5 I just realized there
are tactics in this position because of
the king being in the open on E7 so C5
was played by kukesh he wants to avoid
those kind of tactics there's no threat
C takes B4 a takes B4 back yeah white
isn't afraid of that so he plays Bishop
E3 he pins it but Bishop B6 not putting
on defended Square yeah I think this is
definitely just equal through and
through it's not much to to say here but
it's a great point to be cognizant about
those tactics at all times Knight takes
on E5 if the Knight moves and it's still
there in fact it's always going to be
there
oh and Rook D5 he's going after the C5
Pawn apparently it's a big mistake maybe
just take on B4 and there's outside pass
Pawn potential for black because White's
Pawn goes towards the center now that's
good in early stage of the game we want
to pawn to the center because that
restricts enemy pieces where they want
to be in the center but in the end game
outside pass pawns are super dangerous
and I'm looking at that A6 Pawn that's a
problem for white big problem and you
know what he may have missed is after
Pawn takes C5 seemed like a good move
but I think in that position you could
just go Knight takes on C5 and there's
some pins on the D file so easy to
overlook those kind of awkward looking
tactics
and he gives up an exchange but this is
desperation that's rather than desire
and I'm looking at this position I mean
black will be able to move the a pawn at
some point I keep talking about a
potential pass on B6 potentially the
chisler White's pawns but I'm on we're
looking at a fourth straight win for
gukesh yeah and this move E4 so much
stronger than it looks the Knight could
not use the D2 or D4 squares because of
that pawn so you're forcing the Knight
to H4 E1 both really really poor squares
and I just think Gucci needs to do
exactly what you've been talking about
B6 A5 make it pass on and the two Rooks
should beat the the one rook and the
lazy night that's barely gonna join the
action
yeah Knight G2 might be meant by G5
keeping that Knight banishing it out
from forward squares in fact the Knight
can't get anywhere because then that
goes to G2 G5 and it goes to E1 the 991
dominated by the polymer E4 that Knight
is not participating in this game yeah
C4 91 Knight C2 is is needed so I'd like
to see that sooner than later if I'm in
front of but at the same time as soon as
you switch your knight to the other side
I see H5 and breaking through on the
king side
yeah Rook d8 to h8 pile up on the H2
pawn and the white king could be in
danger so he goes 91 but you know
where's that Retreat really getting him
as you said you go Knight C2 or you get
your knight D4 it takes a long time yeah
but I do believe black needs to be a bit
precise because if you do let this
Knight back in look at that massive
pawns from B4 to D5 those could become
past at some moment if you're not
careful yeah I got the tetris block
there
um if you play D6 takes takes all of a
sudden another Pawn goes to C5 protected
pass spawn and knights are always tricky
remember these are three minute games so
time is taking a little bit quicker
nights are tricky but is he gonna really
get to that time scramble stage where
the Knight is a real problem I'm not so
sure
and G4 he wants G3 he wants to open up
that white king actually like white
King's kind of in a mating net so
bringing the second Rook into the attack
might just be devastating and he times
it well G3 he's just opening it up and
this should be that yep I think you
could probably take this uh Rook okay
decides to double up
yeah the Knight just doesn't support
these pawns Robert I mean you can play
D6 but that's pretty much the end of
your your hopes and dreams there
and the rook's coming to B2 because he
wants to provoke B5 and play A5 that
outside pass Pawn at long last will find
himself roaming up the board yeah and
watch out for C6 B6 D6 that's a
breakthrough if you play A5 I'm just
wondering about C6 I think you've got to
take it
yeah you you grab it on C6 and it feels
like White's pawns they're just there's
many of them but not quite enough and
the a pawn does run quickly
enough no breakthrough works here then I
think we might actually see in reaching
for the resign button on takes is
important and of course Very trivial
move for someone like goukash
yeah just so A4 is there Knight B5 okay
there is a a little bit more caution
required so he brings his King in gukesh
way to principle of a player and can
even take that Knight on B5 and just
play King D6 and win that pawn and game
I think that might have been a way to do
it as well but he's spoiled for Choice
here
too many options
this is easy very straightforward bring
your Rook back to B4 then the king
cannot approach the a pawn and A2 wins
the game
does have a choice it's like do you want
to allow white to have a position with a
bunch of Pawns and a knight against your
lone Queen so he opts to totally prevent
that
he intentionally allow this I don't
think he did so decent check is a great
move if you take C5 his check winning
The Rook so he slides back to d8 but
that's a scary moment for a player they
don't have the eval bars to look at it's
true yeah D6 King takes there was Pawn
to C5 forking it just shows that you
know pranav is never really down and out
so he just takes on C6 good idea from
cash now he takes everything he wins the
night he wins the game he has his first
lead of the match five and a half four
and a half in gukesh's favor that's
right and I think we've been talking
about important games important moments
Robert I would go so far as today I
think bernav has the answer right about
now because it's gonna start pulling
away the match score is gonna
just slowly get out of hand if he
doesn't score at least a draw to stop
the bleeding
amazing stretch of games from Gucci he's
just playing much better quality and for
pranav is it's a tough moment because
you know how strong gukesh is and we've
talked about that video that's been
posted on Twitter uh these two is the
chess space India video from about six
years ago when they're very very young
and they're talking uh together but
right now pranav needs to find his
footing and I just don't know how he
does that like how do you stop someone
who is 27.50 almost when they're on a
rampage
I don't actually think you can if a 2750
starts playing at their level or above
you actually just can't stop them
good luck to you and uh pranav right now
he's a bit passive in this opening but
it's well-known territory where white
has a lot of space but how do you
actually break through there's no
inroads to get at Black's pawns here's
some of the D6 Pawn looks weak but it's
well defended
yeah now we didn't see D5 on the
previous turn wondered if it was
possible but he didn't like Knight B5 so
he's bringing the queen back but I feel
here that D5 needs to occur now because
E5 isn't playable but him not playing D5
I'm getting more and more concerned for
the position Robert because what do you
do with this Knight on E7 it's like the
worst piece imaginable
so he plays D5 and I was wondering if he
was certain about pins down the D file
because there's a rook it usually wins a
standard with the queen but there's also
a rook on D1 behind that Queen so for
example Knight D to E2 maybe not this
moment but the point is that you don't
want to take either Pawn for black
because Queen takes d8 gets two Rooks
for the queen
yeah so I I don't know I do feel like
the Knight on E7 was horribly misplaced
for this opening like it doesn't have
anywhere useful it can go the E4 Pawn
covering all the forward squares so I
think that for a few moves here white
needed to make some sort of move like F4
like rookie one just threaten E5 so you
always had an answer to D5 and then you
can just do like literally whatever you
want
um but this is gonna get active it's
gonna be a spicy middle game here and I
think that's what pranav needs yeah I
like what you're highlighting because
that's more in the style of the Roxy
bind In the Sicilian this wasn't a
sicilian but it was a similar type of
structure uh with pawns on the C file
rather than the e-file for black but we
see D5 the break is important and now
for gukesh he does bring his Knight back
to F3 please take me on C4 he says I
will gladly take your Rook on d8 get two
Rooks to the queen and this is exactly
what you were highlighting so definitely
a great idea will we see the imbalance
here because honestly I think it could
be playable and another way to get there
is maybe it would move like 94 but as
long as there's no tactics that are are
in the air with Knight G5 I wouldn't
mind playing two Rooks against the queen
but it looks tough to achieve
he just plays Bishop F5 oh apparently
Knight takes D5 was a blunder
so Knight E4 uh how do you maintain the
connection to that Bishop playing way
too quickly there was good cash oops 94
Robert this is a big problem no matter
where you go that Knight has an amazing
next move you know how I asked that
question how do you stop a 2750 I think
pranav is showing us how it's done this
I mean he's just winning now you're
completely winning in the spot
yeah let him let him stop himself I
guess that's the answer because right
now he is going to have a very
unpleasant decision and this isn't a
five minute game they're moving a lot
quicker we have a full minute advantage
and with only a minute on the clock
facing a tough decision Knight takes G3
coming up oh this looks rough Knight
takes G3 is a move you can pre-move
because if the queen moves anywhere
besides C or E2 you drop your Bishop on
B2 for free but if you brought your
queen to either Square well he's gave
the bishop I mean he's down a full piece
right now is gukesh do you think he was
playing that in case we're not pre-moved
but maybe he just wanted to make you
look bad on air Robert I mean I can't
explain Queen B4 otherwise
I think he knows he's lost regardless of
what he does so he just played in this
way and if I'm kukesh it's still very
early in the match 47 minutes and 40
seconds in the three plus one time
Patrol but I want more games in the
longer time controls so I would consider
resigning sooner rather than later
because I I want to keep getting Blitz
rather than bullet games
yeah I have to say you know I'm I'm
always in favor of uh playing things on
in general you want to sort of age how
your opponent is playing how they're
performing but this is honestly a little
surprising you're down the most
important piece in your position dark
Square bishop and I don't see a shred of
compensation
an A5 which is another precise move does
that Queen want to go back to E1 you're
walking into that same Discovery Knight
takes G3 if you go up to B5 Knight D6
would have been a fork of the queen of
The Rook so Knight takes G3 is there any
problem with that move because now
you're right in that discovery that you
were trying to avoid on the last turn
except you're down to Bishop in the
process so wasn't it better to just play
Queen E2 kind of bite the bullet
previously
probably and he goes Knight D6 instead
of resignation on the spot it is once
again a tied match buddy pranav responds
kukesh has won four games in a row Amman
right now we see the score back to level
five and a five and a half and Buddy is
playing great that was an unbelievable
game unbelievably necessary as I was
just highlighting like I don't know
these guys it's as if they know as well
when those games are so critical to stop
momentum to stop the bleeding they get
the result that they need both players
now have one and what I'll say one on
demand when they needed it most yeah so
now we have a quiet opening the Four
Knights game uh gukesh with the black
pieces a bishop A5 check he's I'm Gonna
Keep My Bishop on the board if you play
C3 I play B5 so you brings the Knight
back to C3 this is an opening win in air
quotes for black I would say yeah that's
right you you have that so white
had the moment to play Knight takes B6
didn't play it and oops now black keeps
it and we'll play C-6 maybe Knight G6
Bishop comes back
and look at that Knight G6 even after
white played Knights were take me how
many times have we said play King h8 in
F5 he's I'll open the f file by simply
trading Knights there and print out
wants no part of it yeah he says no
thank you and it's always disheartening
when you play a move and you're like
yeah now they can't play Knight G6
meanwhile the opponent uh a knight G6
okay your turn it's like nothing feels
worse than that it's true and now it
feels pretty bad in the center where
black is gaining steam but watch out for
sacrifices on H6 that will be looming in
this position especially after Queen F3
so the opening hasn't gone White's way
but I like the chances the Tactical
possibilities here yeah and the G3 Pawn
is so good at handling the Knight on G6
as well if the bishop ever trades for
the Knight then you have the bishop
Community A3 and just the pressure of
the two Bishops in general so tough
position for black because at this point
I don't think you ever want to play
Bishop takes Knight anymore it's not
Pawn takes that has to happen now the
queen can just recapture yeah either
capture looks good I want that Bishop
here so C6 defending the center is good
cash I like that move H4 full steam
ahead is pronounced he's going for it
yeah he really is
um at some point Black's gonna have to
make it you know sort of a big decision
which is like do you play Bishop takes
C3 do you play Bishop takes F5 there's
moves like C6 rookie eight these are
always helpful but I think he's gonna
have to make a sort of larger scale
choice because H5 97 and your knight H6
idea Robert was on tap so there he does
take the Knight on F5 and he goes Queen
C8 offering a queen trade I see the eval
bar it's sliding slightly in White's
favor but I actually really like this
decision from kukesh's perspective he's
trying to get White's most important
piece most aggressive attack piece off
the board
yep and now we'll see a true two Bishop
versus two night position we've actually
seen this structure flipped in Reverse
almost identical the double isolated
pawns the pawn on C6 meaning yeah
there's some weak dark squares there
which side do you like here Robert
between the Bishops and the Knights I
tend to like playing against double
Pawns in Blitz but I also love myself a
good pair of Bishops I would say that
there is dynamic equality and that seems
like a Kappa but I think it's also very
important to think about the pluses and
minuses it's not just we have even
material because there's no plus one for
either side this is a position where
both sides have certain advantages and I
hate the C pawns for white but they're
also very hard to get to and for black I
like that the king feels very safe
thanks to the knights over there but I
don't see any ideas and white might play
Bishop H3 Pawn H5 things of that nature
so I could see a future where white does
go after the black king
yeah and I was gonna say Knight G4 will
force the king back and probably black
will Retreat as well honestly I like
White's position enough to continue but
it's actually the players who kind of
have the opposite it's black who played
on I'm not sure if either player was
planning to repeat but nevertheless we
do have a game continuing here where
does this bishop on C1 go it can't go to
E3 because you dropped the E4 pawn and
some of these variations uh maybe there
are some tactics with the bishop sliding
back to G2 for white but I don't think
you can play Bishop E3 because the queen
takes E4 so if that's the case how are
you gonna connect your Rooks what's your
Rook on A1 going to do
I like the move Bishop to
um F1 because maybe bishop B5 can be
played I was also thinking Bishop to C4
although the move A6 kinda deals with
both of them I like the way gukesh is
handling this but I also like pronounce
clock he is moving very quickly he has a
perfectly good position but I think that
he needs to come up with a plan and
that's the issue that I'm seeing for
white right now the bishop on C1 is such
a problem piece
it is yeah long term though if black
plays B5 it does kind of help white in
the sense that the a pawn is a weakness
getting to trade it off is kind of nice
and you you will be able to Target uh
the Pawns in the future so
um I don't really think that Black's
achieving a lot with this in fact you
could say The Rook on A1 wasn't doing
anything and now if we trade things off
that might help yeah I didn't see the
need to rush that move but I understand
it and the clock is evening up but I
think black can also play C5 to C4 and
shut down the light script oh I don't
like A5 I have to say that pawn looks
like he's gonna get in trouble
yeah do not like that now it feels like
you know the knights can pop into all
these important squares I think trading
and getting rid of that Rook was good
now the Pawn's weak on A5 now the rook's
not doing anything on A1 both could have
been solved by capturing and you still
can't play Bishop E3 so the Bishops
might have to go to A3 but it's not
doing much of anything there either The
Rook is coming to d8 for black suddenly
go cash has the upper hand on the board
and on the clock so what do you think
about Bishop F5 basically if you play G6
I don't know if I'm right but I want to
say hey I'll just go back to H3 in the
meantime I'm dreaming of Bishop E3 just
Bishop F5 Bishop E3 it's true you get a
little somewhere but now he's gonna go
Knight to E7 back I imagine so he can
take this bishop on F5 and black really
does have the upper hand
Yep this is I mean really dislike that
movie A5 however anything can happen
here if the Queen stay on the board we
could even see a position where crazy
enough like G4 G5 could happen after
something like 97. so the bishop finally
develops the E3 uh apparently that
wasn't the correct move but it goes up
to B6 the problem is why he's doing one
move threats structurally White's in
huge trouble
yep I do think that his position has
improved like I'll take the Bishop from
C1 and put it on B6 thank you very much
for sure but look at this Knight seat
what Bishop 1 B6 I'm about to grab that
piece take my knight on C8 why don't you
now you've lost your Bishop pair and the
E4 Pawn is a permanent weakness and yeah
this bishop doesn't really do that much
if you go back to E3 then Queen takes E4
I don't think you can stomach that
position so try to find a way to maybe
sack a pawn and keep going here but I'm
not sure there is he goes G4 I kind of
like the move considering the time but
this is just not enough surely no it's
pure desperation G5 you just take it by
Knight H7 The Rook on D6 is perfectly
placed he preemptively goes Knight to H7
he wants to rap that Knight into F4
Knight G6 Knight F4 yeah
Knight on F4 is gonna hurt very very
strong move
this is uh this is a master class now
for good cash only one second for pranav
there's no saving this position G6 will
happen
it did happen white played it and then
resigned after it was captured and that
was a very nice game from goo catch a
strategic dominance over his opponent
and there was that moment where they
could have made a draw and guess what
gukesh played on and he was rewarded for
it
he was yeah whether or not that was the
objectively best decision I think it
goes to show like we've had a lot of
draws in this match Robert but they
haven't been like oh let's agree to
withdraw and Shuffle the pieces they've
all been hard fought draws right to the
very end
and smarter chess predictions brought To
Us by chessgoals.com they suggested that
before the match good cash was a 67
favorite now he's back around 64 that
number was not uh you look at the graph
it went down from gukesh's perspective
and now back up thanks to his wins in
recent games he's up 1.6 now five and a
half and I have to say this position I
get it from the blackhead all the time
in Blitz and I always struggle I'm
gasping for air Black's pieces have no
squares yeah and you kind of whenever
you have this structure I feel like the
normal thought is oh yeah F5 King's
Indian attack kind of style but White's
the one with that position black has no
support for F5 it's not happening so
where is Black's play
he's slow playing it Queen C70 takes he
wants a rook on C8 perhaps a baby Bishop
to A6 because if you play C takes D5 for
white Bishop A6 you don't really want to
play B5 and hand black that juicy C5
Square
yeah that would be a big mistake white
is looking to leave a Pawn on B4 for the
entire game here if you could yes keep
that Knight on D7 at Bay and you look at
the pawn structure if you could move
that pawn on E5 away maybe the E5 score
would be available it's the Black Knight
so right now Blacklist Rook State taking
over the C file don't play Rook C1 the
queen will take it and then white would
be in trouble
yeah and we're happy to trade these
Bishops as well like Bishop A6 first of
all Queen takes A6 I can't help but
calculate um although obviously moving
the the queen away makes a lot of sense
but suddenly black might have like a B5
Knight B6 at the right moment to free
that knight from D7 to play on the queen
side he says playing the queen side I
will Queen C2 Rook C3 to follow I think
suddenly pranav is doing great
and the time don't forget I mean he's
way up on time this opening for black is
definitely one that you can just get
some some moves out really quickly
really casually uh I don't think that
he's really been calculating too much
he's just trading pieces opening the
file invading I don't think he's going
too deep which is why he has this huge
time Edge yeah he's working by feel and
experience which often is more important
than the objective evaluation that the
bar says oh white is slightly better who
cares if you don't know how to follow it
up and queen A4 what a move going right
after the B4 Pawn I think that White's
position is about to fall apart
yeah we might see Rook B1 and after
cakes Pawn takes black owns the only two
open files in the position so yeah I
mean the the last thing Robert is I'm
looking at the Knights right how does
Black's position improve past that you
mentioned B5 Knight B6 might be time to
get something like that because without
the knights getting involved I don't
know how good Black's position can get
here
it's a fair point and he goes Rook C3
the Knight goes back to B1 so wow if
Rook B3 you might be venturing a little
bit too far it might work out because
the Knight can't go away from B1 the A3
Pawn needs defending uh but just feels a
little awkward to go there I'd rather go
Rook C2 yeah Rook C2 is a more natural
move for sure
um if he wants to keep the speed up I
think he's gonna choose the more natural
Rook C2 just to you know keep the tempo
but it's possible with a little bit of
calculation here that Rooks see or Rook
C3 to B3 might be the decision he makes
yeah because a takes B4 is a huge threat
and now we can steal the A3 Pawn but
look kukesh had this ready he's giving
up A3 because he wants Knight C4 at the
end
yeah that's really interesting he's
gonna get D6 he actually might lose both
the A3 and the B4 pawns but that's how
valuable the D6 Pawn is he's willing to
give it up for that and we see pranav
say no draw for you Rook C2 is the move
a takes before was a threat so good
night E1 hits that Rook on uh C2 Knight
C3 next for what almost traps The Black
Queen hey this is the weirdest game I've
ever seen I get the Rook jumping around
on like four different squares whites
Knights are on the back rank it looks
like it should be so unpleasant but Ted
you mentioned it Knight C3 lucky it's
not game over there now the queen barely
Escapes in Queen B3 and I'll Attack the
Knight and C3 be good for black so
Knight D3 back seems to be White's best
choice and if the Rook can't go to C3
anymore Rook C2 we might get a weird
draw by repetition
so yeah I was looking at Knight B2 I
guess there's Queen C2 so can black just
play like H5 or H6 here one of those
moves to to say okay I'll pass the move
to you don't really see what I'm gonna
do but I know that moving the H Pawn
gives my king Escape square and hey now
it's your turn again I love it from
alpha zero to Amman zero over here
throwing the H Pawn up the board gaining
some space left for the king and white
doesn't really have a plan Rook C3 again
is not going to go back to B1 we've seen
this before Rook C2 Knight E1 Rook back
to C8 but what keeps happening is black
is gaining a Tempo every time these
Knights keep retreating and going back
to their original Square
exactly I mean you could literally just
go back Knight D3 G6 do the whole thing
again King G7 this is a really powerful
way to play he's investing some time I'm
wondering if he's trying to say oh is
there some sort of Knight G4 like
something different in this position and
last position but I don't think that's
the case
it is hard to go back and forth on the
yo-yo string even if you are the side
with the advantage so he's thinking but
he needs to move his Rook I think he's
spending way too much time here and
plays Rook to B2 we have seen this
before
yeah I I would go Rook C2 and I would go
Rook C8 I don't know why he doesn't like
that he just did it with success
she said so much time now I would have
considered making the draw for black I'm
getting worried about the clock he says
I'm worried about what Knight G4 I'm an
amazing bullet player I can handle this
but when the time you know starts
elapsing like this and white is pairing
off the initial threats you have to be
concerned dropping under 20 seconds each
four I like H4 maybe G4 gives up some
squares but King G7 is a great move as
well I think this is how black needs to
be playing no rush no rush he wants F4
does uh gukesh he went Rook a two he
wants to F4 and Rook over to F2 oh Rook
takes before and Rook takes E4 dual
threats and what great timing to capture
that pawn by the way the Rook moved to a
square where suddenly everything's a
little different
yeah now this is just falling apart for
white great understanding of this
position from pranav I thought he was in
trouble because he was spending so much
time he had this all worked out amazing
Google is really gonna have to work here
time is even 16 seconds a piece but the
tougher moves for good cash to play two
threats as you mentioned Rook takes B4
rookie For You Gotta Lose Your Center
Pawn here I play rookie two and maybe
sacked the queen was Rook D2 instead
giving up the E4 Pawn but now he is down
upon the center and has no attacker no
compensation yeah Knight C3 was
available there oh E4 that's just game
over
okay he missed it oh that's a big Miss
though
yeah Queen takes H3 with Knight G4 to
follow that looks pretty good yeah now
the knights hit and you can trade those
Knights Queen H3 he knows exactly what
he's doing here
and eight seconds for black he needs to
play quickly he's now up oh The Rook of
day is hanging oh
he dropped it before
he's got to try E4 and Knight G4 there's
still hope whoa oh the queen is hanging
oh my God is this winning for Black
Knight G4 yeah that was I mean
incredible he blunders how is this game
still going I don't know
how amazing black is still up though
three pawns even Queen F4 trading the
Queens at this point should be a win for
black yeah there's no way to escape the
check so you have to trade the Queens
here
and of course just gonna resign yeah I
mean it is a fair resignation but wow
that game just went nuts at the end
there Robert that was insane I don't
know how he hung a full rook and still
won the game he just dropped a rook on a
good full board awareness from gukesh
but then great understanding from that
his position was so good that when he
dropped the Rook he was still better
because he had the attack and now we're
into the next game it is six and a half
six and if we have a tie and this is
going to be the last game before the
players get a break so four white in
this position pranav just off the win uh
he has all his pieces staring at the E5
Pawn I tend to feel like white should be
better but I never know how to actually
break through and put even more pressure
and I don't think D4 is the way
yeah D4 is a super direct way of playing
right obviously this is looking to break
things open before cash has time to
place his pieces on all those perfect
squares you know you think of the last
move it was B6 right that makes the
Knight on C6 a little bit loose so I
have to say I understand the move d4 a
lot but it may just be too early if you
take on D4 Rook takes C8 takes and
Knight takes D4 wants to happen I was
expecting that though rather than on the
E4 yeah I think now all of a sudden
pranav he's able to obtain what he
wanted and he gets his Pawn on E5 look
at this both sides are Pawns in enemy
territory but the pawn E4 is directly
hanging the pawn E5 is better defended
yeah and I was looking at him I don't
know if it makes sense even Knight D6
here uh for white maybe to take this
Knight on D5 but yeah it's a little bit
messy and he goes for rookie four are we
just gonna see is it like just takes and
takes on E5 I thought seems good for
white
yeah you get the bishop pair so the evil
Bar says black is better which means
there must be some kind of tactic in the
position so I'm gonna try to press and
elimination it gotta be this I'm not
gonna calculate it
oh my gosh it is that no it really is
and you you get a check on D1 and then
black has the move F5 at the end okay
that is a ridiculous sequence it's very
helpful to have the eval bar that's what
I've saved Robert you know I'm cheating
here I got the the guy it's like someone
tapped on my shoulder and said hey
there's a tactic well okay you poke and
prod me I'm gonna I'm gonna find
something good cash is gonna find it
he's looking at it and he's spending a
lot of time on this moment hey oh it
plays C6 so no he did not find it I take
it back that was not a human tactical
sequence no no that was something else
because it's basically like the perfect
coordination to take advantage of
White's pieces and you know the perfect
storm just doesn't happen all the time
um Knight takes C3 might still be
available but I think H4 kind of handled
it there yeah in the type of position
that was was one where white stayed up a
piece for a few moves after the fact but
black was able to kick that Rook around
and get the piece back so very
complicated very very difficult to spot
and in a Blitz game you can't spend all
your time at that stage because you need
time for the rest of the game so we're
in a position where white is up a pawn
but F4 I mean are some of the squares in
front of the white king potentially
vulnerable
absolutely
um I look at this position and I'm
thinking if black doesn't pry things
open white might have a very easy road
to Victory like we need one Knight D6 if
we don't see G5 F6 B5 like any of these
breaks then I start to get concerned
well G5 is definitely going to be
available because E5 will be loose there
could be a rook takes D6 at some moment
and well the eval bar just went all the
way down
I mean it could be something as simple
as Bishop f8
it's the one move attack yeah just go
for that night on D6 so Bishop is there
F5 for white after that
actually you said F5 I was thinking
about F5 right now but I guess you can
take it
a sax exchange on D6 so he tried to take
advantage of the exposed white king and
the fact that the Rook honey one bishop
and C1 haven't developed he played
Bishop D2 you're walking into ideas with
the rook and black queen on the D file
maybe there's like a knight B4 or
something to that effect yeah and also
King H2 which I thought was like an
insanely good move for white there's a
weird Knight F6 with Knight G4 check and
that's really bothersome
so he goes rookie one back I like that
he's defending his first rank uh so
white does objectively have an advantage
but if you look at this it's that Rook
on A1 over there for this Knight on D5
right now the Knight going to G4 to H5
it does look like a very impressive
piece yeah it does
um I really understand the move Knight
to F6 in the sense that you you want to
bring these pieces in but I have to say
allowing Bishop E3 Queen D2 or novice
made some big strides here in the
position but here comes the C pod C5
first C4 second and all of a sudden
maybe don't rush the move C4 because it
allows some ideas with Bishop D4 but I
mean Knight G4 first it plays Queen C7
but the point is that there are so many
squares that Black's pieces are about to
occupy
yeah it's true I still I still really
get a good feeling for white either King
H1 and maybe the bishop has the G1
square or Bishop F3 the queen can slide
over Bishop F3 just temporarily kind of
controls those important squares and
gives the king some room to breathe I
love Bishop F3 and I think that's why I
didn't like Queen to C7 I thought Knight
G4 first should have been played and
queen F2 hitting that pawn on B6 Rook D6
protects it and the bishop watch out for
it it's coming to E5 you you called
Bishop D4 even if we don't get Bishop E5
here if we just get a trade of Bishops
that's an achievement as well for
pranoff so with a minute to 25 seconds
here will we actually see for now take
the lead again in this match Robert
because it's been back and forth but
it's been the good cash comeback show
what about print off this is amazing
resilience from him because so many
players after going in that kind of
losing streak four games in a rogue
catch one they would just break they'd
be like all right he's the better player
like I'm gonna do my best they would
tilt try to get crazy predominantly very
solid throughout the match he's been
playing very precise brand of Chess and
while I like what gukesh is doing here
playing quickly and look at the clock
all of a sudden 30 seconds for pranav 26
for gukesh absolutely and H5 is making
me think in retrospect what about G4 G5
but anyways not played Bishop there I'm
not so sure about what a tactic Bishop
E4 nice find there from gukesh he wins
that Rook on D1 for the cost of a minor
piece and pranav what's he thinking
about he's got to take it he's thinking
of what to take it with yeah I guess so
um there's no way you don't take it he
takes with the Rook rookie for it that's
actually just a fantastic move he
recovered so well from that mistake that
was incredibly classy a queen trade is
winning for whites of Queen C8 was a
necessary move you give him the B6 Pawn
but you have Knight G4 type of ideas uh
White does need to be a bit careful for
the king but there's a queen B8 yeah
Queen B8 oh you can't allow the Queens
to get traded that's a big mistake
Knight D1 he's gonna try but this should
be winning for white yeah though Knight
takes B2 then C3 will be loose after all
Bishop takes A5 protects that pause
at this point does it just run you can't
take with the bishop It's gotta be
Knight takes only only move to try but
good luck catching that a pawn A6 right
now the Knight goes to A2 and then the C
Pawn is running as well Mr wait here
let's see through a tempo
yeah Bishop E3 I thought this was what
he wanted to do but now you can't even
take it it's unbelievable he just lost
the game he just lost the entire game
oh my look at him he is heartbroken and
dukesh is relieved because that was a
win in the bag for pranav but he let it
slip with two inaccurate moves in a row
and guest gets a well-deserved drink of
water and he has a seven F six and a
half lead
oh my goodness Robert that is just crazy
this looked completely when the a pawn
was running he was bringing the bishop
around to E3 but totally forgetting that
the C Pawn runs as well I mean if I'm
still sitting here thinking about that
game you can just imagine that pranav is
doing that you know that emotion
multiplied by a hundred
could have entered the break with a one
point lead in the match now he has a
deficit kukesh he showed resilience as
well uh props to him for not folding in
that engine but I mean that was pronov's
game to win he'd lose it he is now down
by a point so players will take a break
Imani will do the same and when return
is more from the semi-final matchup in
the 2023 Junior speeches championship
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Championship
defending Champion has defended his
title National Master Ryo Chen win match
is over with this game exactly yes wins
the final three games to close out this
match
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we return from a much-seater break for
the players right now go catch the
number one seed leads five seed per knob
seven half to six and a half among that
game should have gone pronounced play he
earned what should have been a victory
but Woulda Coulda Shoulda he didn't get
it done when it mattered most no and
honestly it's still on my mind Robert so
I wanted to bring up the board again
because it just ended so abruptly this
was the position that purnov found
himself in Bishop attacked on B4 you
need to put it somewhere instinctively
you want to bring it backwards because I
mean there's a pawn you want to still
cover the C Pawn but it's actually the
going in the other direction that was
necessary now you have Bishop B8 to help
the pawn go forward and your Bishop can
cover the pawn quite fine from E4 so
realizing that in fact your light
squared Bishop was not necessary to help
the pawn queen and switching to the dark
Square Bishop not something that is easy
to realize Robert with just seconds on
the clock way too difficult the human
instinct is to leave that Bishop on C6
to help promote the pawn and use your
dark Square Bishop to defend against the
enemy passer but that was a step in the
wrong direction we saw the game end
after Bishop D2 Pawn to C3 and then the
pawn just rumbled down the board for
black rather than for white and that was
that game over and a win for gukesh and
a match lead for go cash
yeah no good cash to be ahead after that
game and especially it was right before
a break Robert so it's it's like an
unbelievable Stroke of Luck not only do
you not lose the game you don't just try
it you actually win it and then you get
to like you know like a bandit escaping
uh from a a scene of the crime you know
you just leave uh I'll take my five
minute break see you guys later
well in the players they do deserve that
break and for gukesh he was received a
bit of a lucky break there he probably
should have lost that game if they've
replayed that a hundred times I do think
purnov wins it pretty much every other
game except for that one but that's the
thing of the past right now I'm looking
towards the future of mon right now it's
a one point lead from gukesh how close
does pranav need to keep it to feel
comfortable heading into the bullet do
you actually even think that pranav is
the favorite impola that's another
question
yeah and I think it all comes down to
that you see pranav there one thing that
I can say about him just having played
so many games against him over the years
is that I just truly never seen him tilt
um it's just probably one of his best
attributes and that will afford him well
right now I've win I would be tilting I
can tell you that after that result so I
don't think that he's gonna overreact
he's gonna play his game but I also
think that if this matches even within
two point deficit uh he's still got
great chances in bullet so he's just
such a strong bullet player Robert I I
think he's always gonna have chances and
look at him with the full three minutes
on the clock right now after this two
nights Tango opening uh the knights
thing I don't know what you call it
these days but either way we have
reached a position where white is very
solid and black does the alpha zero the
Iman zero H5 and he's trying to use that
pawn to help give his King some space
but also maybe launch an attack down the
line yeah this one's the Iman zero when
the queen goes uh to h8 then we'll fully
call it the alpha zero but not sure if
we'll make it that far this position is
honestly one of those that's just so
obvious for white to play it's like how
how obvious can I make my moves Queen D2
Rook D1 maybe bishop A3 like very easy
for white but at the same time black has
had this position before has prawn of
and it worked out he got that D5 break
last time Robert he's got it again right
now but this is the problem when you
have so many easy moves you may play one
of those many moves quickly and then it
is the wrong move and Knight E2 was a
step in the wrong direction he should
have played E4 I would imagine to stop
D5 but now the D5 isn't played Black is
free all your pieces are coming to life
and so this seems like a mistake from
goo cash
we've seen after D5 actually that was
the game where kukesh actually blendered
a whole entire piece really
uncharacteristic of him so if there's
one thing that I can say go cash has
kind of shown a soft spot for in this
match it's preventing the move D5 when
he really should here it was E4 the
previous position he also had a moment
to prevent it but loving the counter
play that pranav is able to get in this
opening ukash has to be careful that
history doesn't repeat itself
look at the queen side three on two
Advantage for black and White's pawn and
queen B4 is good evidence of that they
are weak so Queen before he hits the C4
Pawn can you even defend it if you don't
play C5 which may drop the A2 Pawn
it's a great Point um I think at this
point you're already looking for counter
play which is not so easy to convince
yourself that you're straight up losing
a pawn C5 as you mentioned although it's
I mean it's a little bit greedy looking
Bishop takes A2 but there's no way your
Bishop gets trapped there Robert I'm
team take that pawn there might be Queen
A1 so I'm realizing now I might have
blundered because Queenie one even in
this position carries the threat of
hitting that Knight on F6 and through it
the bishop on G7 but guest plays Knight
F4 I think you can successfully take
this Pawn on C4 now and live to tell the
tale
yeah Knight F4 definitely speaks to the
fact that maybe he didn't notice Queen
A1 I I still think after Queen A1 there
was a whole bunch of nonsense tactics
but you're right Queen A1 didn't occur
to me at all and may have been the
important resource but I'd rather lose
my a pawn than my C Pawn right because
you lose the seat pawn and you probably
will also lose your a pawn at some point
look at a simple play from pranab he
stole a pawn put his Queen on A4 you
can't attack the queen anymore from
there and now you're trading pieces 98
just get out of the attack yeah create
the dark Square Bishops black is
cruising right now yeah it's so weird 98
pranava has found that defensive move on
a few games this match and it looks so
awkward but I think it's actually just
that strong you can even go Rook D1 if
you want to fully simplify the game I
love Rook D1 why not does White have any
attack that I should be afraid of I
don't think so so Rook D1 I don't need
to protect my back Rank and the Knight
on G7 is a very good defensive piece as
well A2 is loose Rook D1 is the move I
would play but but he's in for a think
he doesn't want to rush his decisions
yeah it makes sense I think he's used
his time well in important moments Rook
D1 Queen takes and queen back to D7 is
one like really really defensive just
solid way to play uh so he may choose
that or he may look to go more
aggressive because as you pointed out
the king position is actually safe here
for black and does white have a threat
so Bishop takes A2
I would play Queen E7 right yeah Queen
E7 just going after the pawns and then
he goes Bishop E4 he wants some kind of
sacrifice that probably shouldn't even
work out so black make just Queen D7 the
movie you mentioned earlier keep all
your pieces nice and connected that's
what I would do queen D7 once there's no
Queen E7 and I'm convinced that taking
on G6 is just speculation I'm a huge fan
of Black's position and I'm struggling
to find ways to make it work for white
like what is the next move you almost
have to go crazy on the king side yeah I
was thinking about Bishop takes G6 just
hope chest maybe the only type of chest
that keeps white in the game Queenie hey
look at that move you're trying to trade
queens and if Queen D4 Knight E6 let's
try to trade Knights let's get pieces
off the board because black is up two
pawns total but three pawns on the queen
side
yeah and he has to play uh Queen E5
after 96 I think it's the only attempt
gotta keep some pieces on the board C5
actually makes a lot of sense as well
because hang on a sec how does the queen
even keep defending Queen D3 forced yeah
and they keep pushing the pawns right I
would start with B5 and then B4 and then
keep pushing those pawns up the queen
side it's true uh B5 looks like the one
to start with even if you're not sure
the next move Bishop B7 is trying to get
in around behind but maybe bishop C4 and
A5
why not keep all the pawns if you can be
greedy that looks pretty good I'm
wondering you know Bishop takes A6 is
not a pawn I want to give up but he
offers a nitrate saying you could have
A6 but you still have B and C pawns to
deal with yeah I like that decision as
as well there could be some weird Queen
C6 move coming up where you can kind of
try to trap the bishop but no we just
see B4 interesting he doesn't care he's
just pushing Robert can he keep pushing
is B3 too much because you do trap your
own Bishop which I don't love but if I
can get my queen to C2 is black like B3
Queen B2 Queen E4 to C2 I feel like that
should just be a win four that's right
enough yeah that's a good point I was
thinking like Bishop D5 and queen E4 to
try to switch to offense but instead
he's played B3 I do get a bad feeling
playing B3 just just doesn't feel right
but objectively I I agree with you I
think this has to be okay yeah Bishop
back Queen B4 is the plan and if you
trade queens that pawn oh this is a
bishop C4 for white afterwards
Bishop C4 I think there is Bishop C4 but
still you're completely stuck here okay
he goes Bishop D1 yeah that's that's
completely winning now that is such nice
awareness from pranab he couldn't play
Bishop B1 earlier he would have dropped
the B3 Pawn but he does a trade of Pawns
and now that means that it's an extra
Pawn for black and a win for black
because of that past extra Pawn well
done from pranav what a bounce back I
mean what was I just saying I've I've
literally never seen the guy till can
you imagine going into a break after
what should have been a win turned into
a lost heartbreaking finish and
ironically he comes back and in that end
game Robert he kind of won the game in
the exact same way that he tried to win
the last position in except this time it
worked yeah uh this past Pawn delivered
for him on this occasion and now it's
seven out of seven half and a month we
have about 15 minutes left in the three
plus one that leaves us with probably
three games or so uh remaining in this
time Patrol could catch with the black
pieces and apparently he has the upper
hand because he stole a pawn of the set
what is print off doing in this game
yeah he stole a pawn in the center and
yeah he might get it back I was actually
wondering if he was going to play Knight
to B3 instead he decided to take the
pawn this way but even though the
material has been equalized the quality
of the pieces is I mean just in question
right now Queen D7 hits H3 this is going
to open files and you know easy targets
for black ukash has a very very nice
position yeah simple moves for him and I
saw that featured chat uh so I don't
remember your username but think black
has won six games in a row that is not
something you see very often
I can't even believe that even hearing
it
um but yeah I guess it just goes to show
the white pieces and we see it again
right here I have not been super
impressive and destroyed level in the
feature challenges now is that they
hadn't heard of
um pranav before but now they have and
yeah he's Beast level he is an absolute
monster and you see this position he
actually is helping himself quite a lot
in the last bunch of moves I do feel
like black maybe had more of an
initiative at some point to me this just
looks like a pretty normal looking
position where it's sure black is
slightly better C2 is a bit tender but I
think that the last bunch of moves have
favored White
yeah and there's probably a really
critical move here just because I think
if the bishop well if it goes to C1 it's
just clearly your position is much worse
Bishop D2 though also feels wrong with
Bishop takes C2 and D3 as a very tricky
resource there so is Bishop E5 the move
here Robert because there's not many
squares and Bishop B5 feels wrong
it feels wrong to give up a bishop the
Knight can take it and maybe black will
still be better there we see the evil
bar suggesting black is slightly better
but I agree with you that looks like the
only move just now he goes Knight E5 but
the bishop doesn't get trapped because
95 Bishop of F6 the bishop can take back
on D4 because the pressure on G7 is shut
out
yeah so maybe in this case I mean first
of all we have to take this so Knight
takes Bishop takes suppose if you take
right there's just a hanging Pawn on C2
obviously the king is kind of exposed
from this G5 move but there is a pawn up
for grabs here
yeah so we see the exchange on E5 and
this suddenly doesn't look that bad for
what I see the Eva bar really down on
white yeah it's hate in here but if I
had this in a game from either side of
it okay it just looks like a position
where there's some initiative against
the C2 Pawn but even if you win that
pawn that's seems to give white a lot of
life on the king side
yeah and you know one thing I was
actually looking at here is takes takes
Bishop C2 Queen D2 Rook D5 is a big
threat and Incredibly after D3 Rook
takes G5 might lead to draw or maybe
even a win or something so that's like a
weird line there good cash might have
played one of the best moves in the
position because it's so tempting to
play Bishop B5 Robert but that might
have been just a bad move what a mature
move Rook F to E8 was you could steal a
pawn there are all sorts of things you
could do he says I'll settle and it's
not really settling because it was the
best option we see the Evo bar Rook C1
doesn't really work because of these D3
ideas for black and there might even be
Rook takes C2 first Rook takes you two
and then D3 wouldn't be surprised yeah
if that one also works uh so very nasty
tactics in the air and gukesh with a
slightly in the clock
so I think at this point although Rook
D1 is tempting it might just be really
bad because if you trade Queens there
every Pawn is falling on the second rank
I think you might have to play C3 and
just you know okay I lose a pawn and
just play play on from there
yeah although there's a you're setting
up a trap I see you Iman that have to
see three contained twice Queen E5 check
the exposed dark squares around the
black king could be a problem so right
now black is the initiative against the
queen side but the king side is a bit
Airy and that's something that could
backfire for gukesh
I think it's C3 or bust here for white I
don't know what else you do he does play
it I mean it makes sense D3 can happen
but at least there there is a way that
this position turns around Robert right
even though black has this crazy strong
pass Pawn on D3 there are a lot of end
games where hang on the king just comes
over and picks it up and look at gukesh
again he doesn't take on C3 he doesn't
push the pawn he first plays Rook E8 and
he poses the question to pronounce where
does your queen want to go uh is there
anything besides Queen D2 you have to
step in front of the pawn then D3 there
might be Bishop F1 for white just barely
holding on he goes up to C4 but now the
pawn just rolls forward
a very strange decision honestly I think
he's immediately regretting it Bishop's
defending it Rooks coming in and yeah
you almost have to go like King G1 you
can't lose this Pawn but then H3 hangs
B2 hangs
this is just really looking good for
good cash but he needs to play
accurately as Rook takes B2 is there a
problem with that I don't see it at
first glance I I don't see anything
wrong with with Rook B2
can't play D2 it's important to note
because you dropped the Rook so go cash
investing a little bit of time here he
is well ahead in the clock down to 14.2
seconds I'm taking the Free Pawn that's
what I'm doing and let's not forget
Bishop F1 is the intention right you
want to kick the rook and then play
Bishop takes on D3 is Queen E6 and after
Queen D4 check I mean isn't Bishop F1
happening why why is he playing a rook
end game
he says that I can just be better I have
look at much more activity he has and he
probably understands oh Beast City shut
the queen out
wow no he had that move prepared and
with four seconds left there's no way
this is what Bernard wants nasty move
there Bishop to E4 and yeah forgot about
the queen there sliding laterally
um Iman do you think he forgot about the
queen or he's getting ready for bullet I
don't think he forgot
just being polite Robert you know yeah
no I you know he he was trying to be
cheeky over there thinking that gukesh
might blunder or my pre-move but no that
was a win for gukesh that was a
one-sided game uh and what's really
interesting that's the seventh win for
the black pieces in a row when one side
wins they immediately lose with white in
the next game
God I don't know what it is but it's
like no one can catch a break around
here you think about tennis and holding
serve I feel like everyone is just
breaking each other's serve back to back
it's true and so now I think a solid
game might be what the doctor ordered
for gukesh but these players they've
shown that they're willing to take risks
no just solid draws let's play isn't A5
hanging right now
it's very hanging like it's a super
hanging Pawn why doesn't he take that
Knight to D4 Bishop takes d8 hits the
queen Robert so uh yeah that is just a
mistake WIll we finally see a win with
the white pieces and look at pranav he's
upset with himself there he realizes now
that he doesn't get to throw that Knight
D4 move in as you're saying Bishop takes
d8 the White Queen is captured but then
Black's Queen is captured as well and
that's a huge oversight because that
means white successfully steals a pawn
and should have the upper hand
absolutely no that's a big Miss and it
looks like oh you know you're just
winning one of the pawns on the side of
the board it's not that impactful losing
that a pawn is such a big deal here he
plays Knight D4 anyway which is
I mean I don't know he wants the move
like Knight B3 after Queen D1 or queen
D3 but it's not happening Queen D3 is
super accurate yeah so Queen D3 keeps
everything nice and together and if you
trade on F3 you're just trading pieces
he goes Knight F5 trying to get things
at least an interesting territory but
it's not really that interesting is it
can the queen just slide over and it
does yeah he's I mean obviously if Queen
B3 or queen E2 Knight D4 would repeat
and it would be kind of forcing but now
he has to repeat without a threat so
obviously white can just make a move
like Rook D1 and this has been one of
them I wasn't just gonna say more
disappointing games of this match an
early blender and just much much worse
yeah it's two games in a row very
one-sided in gukesh's favor he is the
stronger player between the two
classical chess rating leaves a number
13 in the world so he's very powerful
but pranav was consistent throughout the
early stages of the match he did lose
four games in a row at some point but
they immediately bounced back but just
the style he's playing with right now it
feels like he's playing a little bit
more for aggression for Initiative for
some tricks and he's not keeping the
foundation of his position so steady and
the game might get out of hand so I
actually want to pull up an analysis
board because I'm thinking a few moves
back here there's just one moment after
B3 bit of a mistake by gukesh I was
looking at B5 takes takes and you start
to have these ideas like Rook A2 Bishop
B4 Queen doesn't have a lot of squares
Knight doesn't have a lot of squares
there's some pressure on the pawns here
this might have been at least the last
moment to even try Robert but a bit of a
missed opportunity there because once
white got this move A5 yeah goodbye
counter play Dreams
none whatsoever and what you say goodbye
to counter play dreams you're also
saying hello to a two-game lead for
gukesh something he hasn't had the
entire match if I'm not mistaken he did
take the lead into this three plus one
time Patrol but I believe it'll be his
first two game lead and that's scary
territory for print off it is yeah no
absolutely correct there
ween to C2 Bishop A7 not sure what to
say here this looks like last ditch
effort on the king side but if this
doesn't pull through then I don't I
don't think he's got anything left in
the tank yeah just don't take that pawn
on H4 G4 is a good move uh you know take
mh4 would open up your king G4 closes
that side of the board Knight C7 96
Knight F4 at some moment you'd like to
go for an attack but one night is not
enough and he brings his Knight to H7
and up to G5 I like the start of this
actually I'm starting to look at some
counter play here for black and white
needs to be a bit cautious
right I mean the Knight wants to reach
the F4 Square you play G4 you solve one
problem but you know three four moves
down the road there's another one Queen
F6 and hang on The Rook is paralyzed
wait the bishop is paralyzed as well oh
my gosh 96 you win material back how did
he escape
it's unbelievable it looked done and
dusted but the you know the magical
black pieces strike again but Queen F4
what is he aiming for with that move I
mean you just filled the square you
clogged it that's where the Knight
belongs and is there a threat that I'm
not seeing so odd I mean everyone
watching is like wait a minute Knight E6
right why why are we not going to have
four it's just just incredible put the
queen there instead I still think that
Black's position is tremendous but I
think black's position is good because
of the move Queen F6 and 96. so if the
best idea is to go back I don't know
anymore there's a problem for white that
you want to play Rook D7 but you drop
the C3 Pawn Knight takes C3 would be a
problem so here for white can you maybe
play him with like Knight B6 or Knight
D6 to start trading off some of the
pieces he goes Knight D6 absolutely yeah
it just move that Knight pretty much
anywhere if I'm playing in pronounce
shoes here I'm playing Knight C7 96 and
trying to bring the Knight there it's
like I feel like if you take you're just
resigning yourself to just no more
threats yeah you can't take that but is
the B7 Pawn going to be captured at this
point you don't care about the queen
said who can't you give that up play
Knight C7 play 96 move the queen out of
F4 shouldn't be there to begin with and
he's going for it I mean this is a good
plan for pranav I think it's the right
idea it's it's a little bit of a dicey
position for white to handle both of the
knights coming into position
uh C4 not a good move C5 though makes a
ton of sense finally he goes backwards
Robert he's on the right track yeah and
he's giving up in exchange please take
my Rook says go cash I'll take back with
my Rook there and whatever attack you
hope to have has fizzled out H3 is
hanging but I don't think you are just
grabbing Pawns in this position and
white look shut down the bishop on A7
that piece is not participating
yeah it's true although you do have the
B8 square and an easy target so it's not
like you won't play the rest of the game
but you're right it does not do anything
like it did five moves ago no one barely
any time for pornography plays Rook to
be oh gosh look how passive his pieces
are it doesn't feel good but he does
have one of the best pieces on the board
the Knight on F4
yeah he goes to D4 instead he's using
that dark Square
Knight C4 back Knight takes E5 was kind
of a threat
yeah but once this Rook moves and you
get Bishop B8 I think black's position
really comes alive here and black only
is 7.7 seconds of angukesh he's now down
to 28 himself Bishop Rook D7 hit the B7
plus thread Knight D6 in some positions
just trade yeah maybe your king feels
safer this way that's right but I mean
just incredible by pranab to be in this
position his position has improved so so
much it might not even be easily winning
anymore no it's not at all look at this
he's just put his pieces on excellent
squares and white has one extra Pawn but
because of the pawn structure on the
queen side those pawns cannot move so
Knight B6 Knight C8 where's his Knight
going
yeah I think he's trying to threaten
Rook takes D4 I don't know if he's gonna
go for it but F4 what a move wow F5 he
wins a piece
amazing he just came up with that out of
nowhere with the time pressure as well
F4 was an incredible move I mean if we
can show that again that would be
awesome because he moved it Pawn in
front of his own King but he took
advantage of the fact that the Knight on
D4 was loose so uh credit to gukesh
there he just earned a two-point lead
but that was a game that started well
for gukesh then suddenly was going a
pronov's way and then when the critical
moment arose not much time on the clock
this was so strong Robert because in
fact he's not actually threatening to
win a piece now but he caused pronov to
move the Knight and then F5 was so
strong and meanwhile F5 Queen F6 G5 is
about to win he took a position that was
actually getting out of hand and he
brought it back so that's super super
impressive as we get back to the game at
hand but pranav almost flipped that
around but you mentioned it right are we
at an official two-point lead his first
of the match we are in no one else's
official this is the the final game of
three minute plus one second bonus time
so we are going to see the next game be
bullet Amman I mean this game is very
critical for pranav and what are these
Knights doing now and D6 not an F6 you
want to play E5 but the Knight on C3 is
loose that's right yeah I've actually
never seen a position like this where
the knights are like that and it's
actually completely fine so what's gonna
happen is you defend this Knight let's
say Bishop B2 B4 and yeah you want to
play E5 but guess what you gotta deal
with your knight and if you move the
Knight E4 just hangs yeah this is a good
position for good cash all right B4 play
Knight D5 Bishop takes D5 anybody and
take back with a knight on D5 you keep
an extra Pawn but hang on what about
Knight takes on e4 is that a really
tricky way to maybe win a pawn and keep
upon here nice you keep the bishop pair
and go up the pawn uh well spotted by
you there and this is really bad for
pranav the good thing is he's an amazing
bullet player the bad news is he's
looking like he's about to enter down
three points this is worst case scenario
continually started plus three to this
match
that's right yeah it means that the
swing uh is gonna be you know not only
claiming those three points back but
getting three points of his own so a six
point swing going into the bullet from
the start of this match is just
incredible and pornov is just kind of
doing that chess player stare up to the
ceiling as you're wondering where the
heck it all went wrong Rook H4 look it's
classified as a mistake Robert but you
gotta understand a little bit he's
trying to play moves that might be
dubious but give him some kind of Hope
yeah he gets a few free turns 95 Rook
takes H7 unfortunately you don't have 95
because your Rook on H4 is loose the
negative three has to stay there Bishop
takes F3 is the immediate threat that
gukesh is going for and I think black
can you play F5 sometimes people try to
defend not that black really needs
defense passively he can throw pawns
forward and now F5 looks really strong
because that Rook is running out of
squares
yeah absolutely F5 will will see Rook G3
I think doesn't really make any sense to
me to play Rook F4
um but yeah I mean Rook Rook G3 Knight
E4 and we can we can pretty safely say
that this is not how a rook is supposed
to be on a king side attack right Robert
Rook H4 Rook G4 Rook G3 Rook H3
no what you want to do is either throw
away your H4 pawn and go your Rook to H3
or pry open the files Within movie H5
but Knight E4 take my knight you kind of
have to unless you want to put your Rook
on H3 and we said how bad that looks and
yeah is there any chance I know we're
pessimistic because black objectively is
completely winning and now especially
after Queen B6 is completely winning uh
but I was gonna ask if there's any
chance and the answer is no so I'll
answer it for myself
Robert talking to himself again just
we've told him to stop doing that
um 95 will be captured and it looks bad
because of the dark squares but lean
from B6 to F2 with Rook C2 coming with
onto e3 coming that is gonna be really
tough to handle and I mean talk about
tough to handle that's the best move on
the board right there yeah what a nasty
move the G2 Pawn is pinned if you take
on F3 e takes back threading Checkmate
in one and I know gookash has many fans
I'm on but it looks like he has a fan on
him I see his hair like moving a bit so
he's he's cooling down while his chest
is heating up
that's uh that's what they call those uh
those Icy Hot patches you know he's got
got one of those going on right here
Queen B2 I mean the guy is ready for the
L'Oreal commercial it's like you know
you got a chess match to play at five
and a L'Oreal commercial at eight
and Rook C2 right now oh my gosh it's
too much Firepower uh in this position
and well if you could trade off all the
heavy pieces maybe white would have a
chance an opposite colored Bishop ending
but I don't see how you trade two Rooks
and a queen here
yeah this is it this is a lot and even
if you got there it's like it might
still be lost
probably is yeah you're right so 19
seconds less than that now for pranav a
very sad conclusion to the blitz portion
of this match
and you can see it on his face it's
registering with him just this is going
wrong Rook D2 maybe question mark you
know uh want to trade something
Rook takes G2 now that Rook is pinned on
G3 oh yeah that's a good point yeah
that's just game over
yeah he's kind of doing that uh doing
that stare into the camera where he
knows the game is done and officially
that is a win for gukesh and also
officially Robert we're at the end of
the three plus one segment look at
gukesh feeling much better about this
match now yeah ten and a half to seven
half in his favor and what that really
means is because he was down three and a
half to half he's up nine to four in
recent games right so uh he has just
been or it's like a ten to four I can't
even do math he has just gone on the
tear you see it he tied the five plus
one portion by winning his last three
games he wins the three plus one segment
six to three so amounts all coming down
to the bullet the question is can print
off Mount that comeback
well I think this is right at that
amount of games where look guess what
it's bullet this can absolutely happen
for front of but I was saying I think he
could be down two games going in the
bullet and that was like kind of the
maximum he's down three so I gotta be
honest I think it's a little bit too
much right now if gupcash even has an
average day at bullet I think that's
enough to win this match given the fact
that he's got the lead going in but it
is bullet and I think we'll have a good
idea Robert in game one how it's going
to go so we'll see what kind of
pronounce shows up
yeah that remains to be seen after the
break but before we head to the break we
just want to give you an opportunity to
join the officialchess.com Community
Club this is the place to be for all
info on community not the TV show don't
worry but for tournaments giveaways
contests and other events plus connect
with the community and stay up to date
on the Chess World use the command
community in chat to get in on the
action and speaking of action as you all
join the Community Club the action will
continue in the junior speeches
championship this is the semi-final
match between gukesh and pranav we'll
see you on the flip side of this break
foreign
I've been using it for a long time I
mean if you look up here I actually have
my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got
unjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to
show they like how many testable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
stressful it's actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 2774 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really is
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
for the final time Patrol of this junior
speed Chess Championship semi-final
match between good question pranav right
now dukesh has a three-point lead over
his opponent for knob Aman it started in
the opposite direction three-point lead
for pranav but since then all good cash
that's right uh I do want to point out
though Robert that if we've seen that
three-point lead vanish once in this
match it can happen again and I think
the most unpredictable time control the
most ballistic time control and the one
that pranab would want to be in to prove
his chances is bullet guess what he's
here he's about to get into some one
plus one chess I'm very curious to see
how that increment plays in to the the
two players playing bullet because
they're probably played so much one plus
zero chess how are they gonna handle the
increment
and bull chess is very nerve-wracking
and if it weren't just the chest there's
so much at stake in this match a lot of
prize money and of course the players
they're in a competition they always
want to win and move on so you see the
winner advances to the junior speeches
Championship Finals the total event
prize pool here in uh the eight player
knockout is 45 000 the winner earns of
this mattress four thousand dollars plus
a split of four thousand dollars based
on win percentage that means they earn
more than six thousand dollars for
winning this match with more money to
come in the jscc final and the jscc
champion gets a spot to the speed Chess
Championship that's the ultimate goal
for these players among we saw gukesh
now on screen we saw last year in the
speeches Championship he lost a Magnus
Carlson he would like to return and do
better and for pranav this would be
really a huge opportunity for him to
make it all the way to there and a
chance with the top players in the world
absolutely and you know you think about
pranav and what it would mean to him
it's also the number one seed that he's
facing so this is probably his toughest
challenge so if he can get through this
I mean it's not going to get much harder
than good cash
no it's true who Cash number 13 in the
live classical ratings and with a
three-point lead in this match we are
off it is bullet chess it is going to be
fast paced and right now both players
with more time they started with yeah I
think we might be seeing that uh in a
few of these matches here we've seen
this opening before so nobody changing
things up as we get into this Knight E4
and Knight D6 is a very common plan here
to just get rid of that light Square
Bishop
and look at buddy pranav's clock one
minute six seconds it's good for him
that he plays hyper bullet what's that
when you start with 30 seconds that's
all you get for the whole game he is so
used to playing with no time on the
clock that he is playing at some of the
fastest speeds that you'll see on the
server absolutely we see H5 H4 now if
Pawn to G4 I'm immediately thinking to
be sack there uh but he didn't Pawn goes
to H3 and I feel like in bullet a Pawn
on H3 is worth a lot even though
objectively it might not be the best
yeah that's right you kind of throw the
eval bar out the window unless it's
completely and obviously winning this
position slightly better for white slave
better for black the players don't know
that they're just trying to cope with
ideas yeah and in this position
strangely enough sometimes you can play
moves like Bishop D5 to like win The
Rook I actually wouldn't do it here but
it's just one of those moves that you
can think about
it's funny that the reason you wouldn't
do it is because the pawn on C6 is so
important keeping the Knight out of D5
and guess what I said keep the Knight
out of D5 he went B4 to go B5 but then
Bishop f8 hit the rook and the B4 Pawn
behind it black has the upper hand right
now but white has the lead on the clock
he's playing this very well but it's
almost that like unfortunate situation
where you win material but then you're
unhappy to take it
that's true the dark squares around the
black king might be a problem but right
now white doesn't have attackers over
there the bishop on F1 is passive the
Knight on C3 dominated by the potency
six and off come the Rooks a great
decision from pranav yeah The Rook wants
to use the default but be careful Bishop
C5 A6 and that A7 Pawn is loose why
didn't he go back to C5 a huge mistake
yeah that was I mean he just missed that
B4 could be captured I guess and he
wants an attack but F6 hits the bishop
on E5 and the bishop is nowhere to go
because the Knight C3 is loose yeah that
might I mean it might get really weird
after Bishop C7 there but that would
have been the move
oh and queen E7 watch out for your king
yeah where does he go now Rook D7 Queen
E8 doesn't make any sense to allow that
instinctively
he goes working with A6 the bishop on F1
is a great piece all of a sudden yeah
Pawn to C4 though one move away from a
check a huge check at that
oh and queen B3 Queen three check Queen
takes F3 this is a problem for white all
of a sudden huge problem Knight C3 only
move but then the C4 movement Queen D6
and queen F2 is about to happen
oh be careful it was Bishop before to
keep the queen out of there white has
the upper hand by the way look at how
fast kukesh is playing 32 seconds on his
clock it's incredible Queen d8 and
Bishop C5 now Queen F6 even better
that's nasty that's a win for gukesh a
four point lead I am just so impressed
by kukesh his bullet rating right now
everybody it is 31 27 he's one of the
highest bullet players on the site wow
just wow that is quite something
remember you know pronounce an amazing
player but he was made to look slow in
that game kukesh was like 30 seconds up
on a guy's speediest pronoun
and historically gukesh is not much of a
bullet player nothing he's not good at
it he just doesn't play it and he beat
Amino high in eight to two to gain much
of that rating and now he's saying
pranav you're at 3 100 yourself hey this
is just imagine I'm happy to be even
with you here because I started with a
three-point lead now it's up to four
yeah a great position here though in my
opinion for white Bishop comes to D6
you've got E4 in there you are up a pawn
the Knight is so somehow just holding
everything together
and you see The Rook can just move back
as you point out the C5 Pawn is extra
and the black queen would like to go to
A5 and try to you know wreak some havoc
on the queen side yeah but the bishop on
D6 that is such a good piece yeah upon
to C4 I mean Pawn to B3 is about to
happen this is an amazingly good
position for pranav who's also playing
quickly
and that's right Brennan Causey is about
to get wild it's already been wild
thanks to everyone who's been here for
the ride and there's still much more
action left 25 minutes plus on the clock
that's plenty of time for pranav to make
this comeback absolutely I mean the
first thing you need to do is actually
bring it back to what it was before the
bullet started that three-point deficit
yeah one game at a time I know it's
cliche but it's really necessary you
know you have plenty of time but you
can't go all in you can't just sacrifice
pieces speculatively not against a good
cash that's for sure and now White's up
two Pawns
yeah Knight D4 the queen comes back to
E4 and don't think I'm seeing any
problems with with that position white
seems to be just picking up Pawn after
Pawn
I was gonna say is there an F5 but no
there's Queen E5 check after Queen E4
that's a good point so
setting it up though it with E5 so
exactly what we just said maybe King
oh King G2 but 10 F5 you gotta make sure
you stay on that diagonal too
yeah like the queen go to B7 but the
queen might get trapped over there so
King G2 played I think F5 Queen B7 check
is just enough for white and now go cash
plays it he's done under 20 seconds he
hides the King on H6 there must be
something going after that black king
yeah C3 might be a very very good move
here where does this queen go though F7
you're just trying to survive takes Rook
D7
oh there's the mating net here it comes
both look really good yeah 56 Rook G8
that protects the pawn but he goes Rook
D7 he sees a mate here the Knight on A4
is hanging but unfortunately this queen
G7 check H4 check Queen 66 mate yep that
will just see that play out here we go
even better Queen uh G7 and a little
Pawn mate to close uh things out here oh
he's gonna sack the queen of course
no Pawn made for us guys
for goo cash lose on time here just let
the time elapse and that way you spend
more time off the match clock still 23
minutes and 30 seconds and now it's a
three-point deficit once again pranav
Strikes Back yep yukash is already
starting to be smart with the match
clock and you know as he should he took
the lead in there what's the point of
having that lead if you're not gonna use
it
yeah you don't want to have the lead now
you want to have it at the end of the
match so just waste that time so to
speak and that's a smart plan so right
now with the black pieces buddy pranav
he's saying my king can't get out of the
center just yet but I have good
placement on my pieces and that Bishop
on G2 your extra Bishop yeah you're
staring into a brick wall yeah this
looks like prep I'm just gonna go ahead
and say that like Not only was this a
very specific move order Queen E3 Knight
H4 but also B4 while the Bishop was
pinned to get B5 quickly rate stuff but
look pronounce hanging in there and
saying look this is a bullet game
doesn't matter if you get a good
position out of the opening it's all
about the middle game
it's true and right now Bishop takes C3
rookie two was a threat Knight D1 you
noted that it was all prep and we've
seen it from gookesh before but I don't
like how this game has gone for him yeah
this looks like C4 B4 E4 so many squares
for the black pieces everyone's happy
here
yeah except for this Rook on A1 and
Bishop Rod C1 those pieces are certainly
not happy Queen D7
um you know a calm move a knight coming
to E4 I thought was better to stop this
bishop trade that's right yeah now the
Bishops traded an A5 Pawn is loose we've
seen for enough drop that a pawn and
what he just did it again
yes but now he has Knight C4 Knight
takes E4 Rook takes E2 that should get
dicey yeah that's I was looking at
initially at Rook takes E3 but of course
Rook takes uh probably not what you want
to do he goes back to defend it instead
of that move Knight C4 which was really
sharp
yeah maybe he thought that the
liquidation would help white in some of
these ways but I think when you play
rookie and Rook A8 back you know this
game is trending in the wrong direction
yeah Rook c80 might do here but then
Rook C5 just hard to defend everything
Rook 66 is not
it's not because you would have traded
played Rook C8 so actually he could have
lured wow cash into a trap
Knight A8 you're not happy to play that
move but you didn't really have many
options Knight E4 here
he goes for it Bishop takes Rook takes
H3 he's hanging don't forget about that
pawn that's right
because King that Knight gets the B4
suddenly black is in charge yeah
actually it could go to either side of
the board and be happy so he doesn't
want it moving at all with Rook B7
understandable
and now 96 as you pointed out heading on
over to the Kingston or Knight A6 into
B4 it's a very active Square where
you're defending C6 yep either one looks
okay here 94 I mean yeah actually coming
into E5
that's a bit annoying
is Knight takes H3 a threat that's a big
question that I'm about because the
Knight on G4 is about Lucy Goes F4
another great F4 from goo cash that
looks really strong
I almost want to play Knight H7 to be
ready for Knight F6 after Knight E5 but
he's just losing material here playing
Knight C7 Cube up the exchange and put
your knight on D5 he goes to d8 he not
even keeping the exchange and now his
Knight's in a worse position yeah the
Knight doesn't have the D5 Square now
he's trying to get it there but it's too
late the Tempe has been lost
hmm and white 12.3 seconds plenty of
time kukesh has been very fast oh Queen
H5 I like that that's a big move
G5 and G4 us it's so tough to make work
here but he's gotta try where's that
Niko and keeps getting kicked around
nowhere good to go H4 closes the king
side and now this C6 Pawn is under
attack with 26 protects it yeah he wants
the 996 every single Pawn is falling
Queen offering a trade which cannot be
accepted and with two seconds left can
for not find anything here to keep oh he
did Rook takes e Ford C7 is a problem
get a new Queen yeah
oh there's not much to try you should
resign immediately and he gukesh went on
time it's a four point lead once more I
mean pranav he struggled in that game he
just couldn't find the right squares for
his pieces
yeah and these these points really add
up because it sounds obvious to say but
every time that gukash wins it's puts so
much more pressure on pranav because
renov doesn't just have to win one
anymore he has to win one to get back to
where he was before and then he has to
win another one and he's got to do that
process like four times and he's playing
gukesh who is an amazing chess player
and 3100 Plus in bullet and I have to
say I have been very impressed with
gukesh's bullet skills just because I we
haven't seen much of it from him but
when he played the speeches championship
last year against Magnus Carlsen he
scored four points if I'm remembering
correctly against magnets in bullet so
he's clearly capable and normally when
you play high rated players I'm on I
think you would co-sign this you tend to
want to get to the bullet and try to
beat them there but if it can't be
Mission bullet you're in trouble in
these matches yeah where can you beat
him I mean scoring four points against
Magnus is quite Sunny squaring points
against Magnus is impressive that's
start with that so four of them is is
fantastic but we're in the thick of it
here in this game pranav with the time
advantage and you know while I don't
love renov's position here at least he's
got that strong Knight on F5 which will
always give him attacking chances yeah
monster Knight sacrifices on H6 or G7
and that's why Google takes it and after
Pawn takes F5 I think he said with the G
Pawn is black gonna play Knight F4 gonna
Retreat if E4 I think he takes on G6 now
I don't know if that works uh between G3
check uh that's a good point Queen
yeah Queen G3
where's that King going that that was
missed that was the idea I think he was
calculating Pawn takes here but it has
to be Queen G3
yeah Queen takes H3 and Bishop C7 at the
end oh
amazing
what a calculation he can just give this
up and what's the material count after
that F4 Pawn takes a knight G4
all the black pieces are coming to the
attack and this is amazing because white
can take a rook on E8 get a new Queen
with check and so black temporarily will
be down a rook and a bishop and yet it's
still completely winning because
Checkmate ends the game unbelievable
what a calculation like to feel
comfortable being down what a piece and
a rook it's amazing yes it is just
gukesh on fire is what we are seeing and
pranav he's letting his time elapse but
he can't find a single defense there is
no that exists
I mean you have to take the Rook right
you feel like at some point but it just
doesn't help you yeah what a game like
you catching me but I'm shaking his head
but that's one of those head shakes
where you're not really disappointed in
yourself as much as kind of impressed by
what's being thrown at you
just sick play from gukesh I mean since
the first four games of this match he's
been a totally different player right he
started off incredibly slowly he was
down three full points and it looked
like pranav not just had a chance was
the favorite to win the match and then
gukesh stormed back and he's been
Relentless yes
um at this point we really need to see
something different from pranav or the
match will just end we're at that moment
16 minutes on the match clock and the
deficit is you know 13 and a half to
eight and a half so Five Points which
means guess what you have to start
winning right now I think mathematically
speaking you know if he loses this game
he'll have to win the next six in a row
so he needs to get this game does pronov
and his position looks pretty solid from
the black side over here I tend to enjoy
playing against this backwards C Pawn in
these structures so yeah I'm happy for
pranav at this point yeah this this
looks good for him but you know one
asset that cash has always had is how
quick he he plays these positions even
the ones where he's maybe not loving uh
the position so much he still plays it
quickly and that puts pressure on
pranavin it's been that pressure every
single game Bishop H2 like he's just
finding these easy moves to play
and pranav has built a lead on the clock
so that's good news for him and oh E4
apparently not the move why is that
yeah honestly I I think the uh the
reason might have been a little
counter-intuitive but nevertheless renov
has got a fantastic position here
probably would you say is his best
bullet game that we're looking at right
now oh yeah and look at this position I
mean his pieces are flowing D4 is loose
all of Black's piece are defended every
single one The Rook uh on CA protecting
C4 the bishop on F7 also doing the same
it's a one-sided game in pronounced
favorite just what he needs yeah Rook B1
Knight D2 everything is loose and
actually after Knight D2 that Rook it's
surprisingly is trapped
that's wild you don't expect to see
Brooks Trap like that so trade Brooks on
C8 first yeah and then you can even
throw a knight takes F3 check but you
don't need to rush it you in that fact
this move order forced white to shuffle
with the rook and now Rook C4 for black
seems to make a lot of sense and this is
just great I like that you have Rook d8
big blunder but other than that I mean
you could probably just take this and
cover the seventh rank is that just a
nice easy easy way to play
King F7 King E6 oh it goes G5 what
uh that was a pawn to be taken right
ah because it was going to be a a skewer
down the E file at the end yeah that
actually yeah missed the opportunity
yeah very tough to see that though I
Only Could See with the assistance of
knowing that the eval bar was jumping in
One Direction right it goes to zeros
like why would it be oh
right now you see that black is up two
full pawns and the a pawn should just
run at the board white does have some
compensation thanks that H Pawn that's
running quite fast as well yeah he has
more compensation than he should put it
that way Bishop D4 probably
yeah that Bishop helps the a pawn
promote and stops the h-pawn at the same
time
h7s oh
yeah that's weird not to play
H7 here wow
oh my good is it pranav had 30 seconds
yeah so much time and just art breaking
it's gonna be a queen with check by the
way
actually yeah you just I think do you
win The Rook here it's actually not so
easy to win that Rook King E2 and has
Queen D6 though he walked into it and
you can see how hard he is yeah he just
slams the table and you know the maybe
the biggest loss of all was on the clock
right the match clock is down to 12
minutes and 30 seconds he's down by six
points so you only need one second
remaining to start a game they're still
mathematically is a chance but Iman
we're honest people here this looks like
gukesh is match and it means that he'll
move on to the jscc finals yeah the the
other thing is that you also have to
look at what just happened and say if
you can't win those positions what
positions are you in because you're not
going to get many chances better than
that against gukesh in this match
overall so you know it just it just kind
of speaks to how it's going so far and
this game is going just like our games
in Blitz I love playing the hippo and
right gukesh seems to be a fan of it
himself and it's quite a spicy position
where the now it's opening up and that
would give both sides chances here
yeah obviously that's what pranav is
looking for
um he's still trying to shake off that
last position also there's a hippo style
of of play might be a bit of a tactic
from gukesh to elongate the games he's
just saying okay take this very close uh
position and hey it's up to you to break
through so go go ahead and calculate
gets in a D5 move that pranav has been
showing to us all match The Rook comes
the d8 to support it there's a lot of
pressure down the D file and apparently
that move was a mistake why is a
question I will maybe never answer
exactly oh that's that's one for the
history books
and Akshay 16 says gukesh is better in
both than I expected him to be I think
that's the case for every participant in
the jscc that many of the others are
known
bullet aficionados we have Veronica he's
playing bullet all the time prernav
always playing bullet Dennis lesovic
plays Bullet regularly and then you have
gookash who doesn't play bullet very
often and then when he does he shows
that yeah I'm kind of good at this thing
exactly now super super impressed and
you can only sort of tip your hat to the
way good cash is playing right now
despite some very good positions for
renov they're just not panning out so
it's like cash is drawing or winning his
bad positions he's not even losing them
and then he's of course winning his good
positions
of course he brought his King out to F6
which apparently was the best idea in
the position I mean this is how talented
he is I mean King F6 here is actually
the safest it would be it would if it
hit it on the eighth rank white maybe
had time to get the Rook over to H1
first but that black controls the H file
although white controls the C file and
that's dangerous for black
yeah if you move the bishop Rook C7
happens and Rook 2h8 just doesn't make a
threat Rook takes Z6 is with Chuck
oh so suddenly he's turning around for
pranavio's Rook cable there's got to be
a pin down the C file it should win for
white Rook C6 oh
that is a good spot Obviously good cash
is upset he immediately noticed oops
that's the first real series blunder
we've seen the game's not over
not at all I mean queen h8 is an idea
for black going after the white king and
if your King has to run to F2 there's
Rook H2 for black yeah I was thinking
Bishop F1 and just kind of yeah have the
have the king there but this is not so
simple I I think Bishop F1 and if the
Rook comes down somewhere go like Rook
C7
yeah that's true that's good wait he he
oh he induced it he said this is a
mating net so I'll give you my queen and
I'm gonna win yours right back yeah
interesting then he's got that Apon it's
kind of clever
that was really like D3 and Knight takes
B4
okay the Knight escapes to E6 yep or F5
even better
but I mean look how much time Gucci just
wasted just finding all that
yeah it's been an impressive display of
Defense but at long last pranav is going
to score this Victory and gukesh he's
just gonna play it out because that's
good match strategy
why not
and this game's been going for a little
bit Checkmate in two at the same okay
it's three but I can give up the night
first but it's about to be a Checkmate
and gukesh he's just gonna let his time
go out or maybe he will see himself get
checkmate it
and time elapses pranav gets a win but
only eight minutes remain in the match
and it's a five point spread possible
but only if pranav wins every single
game instantly
yeah so what you're saying is there's a
chance I am saying that there is in fact
the slimmest of slim a non-zero
chance yeah I mean if you look at how
long that game took it was actually a
four minute game uh and those types of
numbers are not going to cut it hernov
also just chucked a pawn uh I think he's
got that wry smile on his face now where
that's almost like a okay this thing is
over because he just played H3 when the
bishop was blocked with the Knight on D7
he's just playing too fast because he
needs to and Robert I just don't think
he's he's in this match anymore
nah it's not gonna happen and I have to
you know say the current prediction 92
percent in gukesh's favor that's wrong
it's like
99.9 yeah that's actually surprisingly
low yeah that has to be you know just
turn it up a notch because this mesh uh
we're just being honest with you all it
is effectively is over with only six
minutes and 50 seconds now remaining in
a five point deficit in fact all go cash
needs to do is play this game out and
then he can probably lose all the rest
of the games on time exactly just
sitting there and he would win the match
yep yeah and this one I'm not even sure
that he's gonna play out and draw or
lose no he just might play it out and
win it because his position also looks
overwhelming here with the white pieces
yeah oh look at this trading the Queens
because there's Rook da check at the end
if you take it could also have taken the
pawn now that I think about it
oh there was a better way of doing this
very same thing exactly and I think C4
would have been a stellar move
instead we get here the Knight on G5 is
almost trapped but I guess it's not
because E4 is hanging E6
I'm I'm actually really really mean
Bishop takes everybody takes Rook D7
playing equal Rook end game which is
just cruel
so instead of winning quickly you draw
slowly oh yeah that's actually much
worse
I kind of like it slow death
that's very cruel but it makes a lot of
sense if Rook A5 Knight takes E4 next
and then I can go into F6 and white is
probably just gonna win this game yeah
oh Knight D6 and I think I think it's
done from here he's even gonna resign
the game of course at this point you
want to resign and like start the next
game as quick as possible but it's also
you just know kind of the match is is
over
um when the the lead has just ballooned
now to back to five uh five six points
so unfortunately Robert I don't think
we're going to see any comebacks here
kukesh is
31.46 rated in bullet on the site like
he is getting to the territory where
he's at the top of the leaderboard and
maybe he should keep playing bullet uh
but for his classical chess for the you
know type of Chess he wants to play he's
going to stay away from bullet I'm sure
uh but for gukesh it's been an awesome
match and I just want to point out that
pranav does have a lot to play for in
these next couple games we said it's
four thousand dollars to the winner and
the remaining four thousand dollars is
split by win percentage there's a lot of
money at stake with each point that
print off can score exactly so I mean I
think it it makes it nice for the fans
that while you do see the players tilt a
little bit they're they're also not ever
fully on tilt right because they know
that each of these bullet games is 50
bucks 100 bucks I mean there's a lot on
the line
and we have a great position here where
black castles Queen side after White
Castle's King side whose attack is going
to come first don't take that Knight on
D4 don't open the C file so the queen
sits on D5 and I don't think Bishop
takes D4 is something you want to do so
he plays rookie one giving that Knight
on D for giving a Pawn on that square
yeah the thing is he's happy to lose a
pun there but only if you give away the
darks were Bishop if you lose upon there
by trading only Knights that's not quite
what he wants no and he wants queen
takes G2 Checkmate does gukesh F5 work
oh goodness that Bishop is gonna be shut
out of the game after F4 he was
threatening mate by the way yeah he was
but now his Bishop is entombed oh
wait a second he's too clever
he is clever
that was nice
that was uh you know a little uh docito
there Queen goes up down up and then
Bishop joins it wow wow you gotta swing
your partner round and round and he just
steals this Pawn on F4 and now it's good
cash down under 18 seconds and he just
didn't see that coming yeah it's like
you know you may have won the match but
you lost this calculation battle
and that doesn't feel good chess players
they want to win every single battle
that they take part in and I don't see
another options like Queen G3 here C7 is
hanging so that's why the bishop was
captured and isn't white a pawn a head
and yeah see the oh gosh Bishop F3
Knight of the Equator Queen takes d8
check was there that's incredible yeah
if there's ever a a thing to miss that
would be it at the top of the list Queen
F4 rookie five looks fantastic though
oh it's very direct yeah he's all over
this position Queen to G6 and maybe even
Knight H4 there
and he plays G4 which means the pawn is
defended very very well and now white is
up two pawns and it might just become
three
yeah after Bishop okay interesting
Bishop D7 now I think we can move the
Knight maybe Knight ditch H6 yeah I like
rookie too just to
bring the roof back and give up one Pawn
but obviously be winning
it's what gukash did in the previous
game right traded Queens by force I went
up material and so pronoun says let me
just trade pieces I am up two Pawns
oh one Pawn now yeah yeah you know it's
always a good idea until you do it so
often that suddenly you don't have any
left and Rook D2 check takes B2 and now
you're up zero pawns yeah wait a minute
okay now it's it's a little too much
right
at least the pawns are rolling very
quickly but black with an outside pass
Pawn of his own
mm-hmm oh is Knight F3 the right way to
do it
um
yeah because the bishop is so long range
I guess 94 is a really good move oh yeah
take on A4 and then broke H1 G5 well
done there by print off yeah this is I
think we're in the territory where
pranav may win this one and you know
he's definitely gonna take some of these
final points away from gukash but as you
can see the match clock this is very
over in terms of the actual map
yeah but I mean he's winning several
hundred dollars exactly with his wins so
it is very worth it for pranav to keep
playing and try to score another Victory
if we get one more game which we will
because he can just ladder Checkmate
this out very easily
you can't see the the long way down he's
gonna resign the game because I think he
knows that the match clock will expire
no matter what uh before this next game
ends so this is the last game of the
match and you know the the final score
will be so dangerously close to smarter
chess's prediction it was 16 to 12.
Robert that was the smarter chess
prediction if this ends 15 and a half to
11 and a half I mean uh I hate it when
he's right it's funny because he's right
in the completely wrong way right he
said that gukesh was a one point
favorite in the longest time control
then two point favor in the three plus
one but the game soon the match also
started with three and a half out of
four for pranav so since that rough
start uh since that first break gukesh
became a different player and for pranav
uh things didn't go his way he's playing
one of the best chess players on the
planet one of the best prodigies in
chess history so he can hold his head
high and he may in fact win this game
and if he does he'll win the final two
games the match earn some very hard
earned cash and move on to his next
event
absolutely and um I was about to say
interesting with Bishop C2 so he does it
now I was wondering if he wanted to
trade Rooks or not
um because the Knight is loose here so
some some final tactics by pranav and
he's I think he has a bishop in a weird
position yeah so Rook takes E1 check
Rook takes E1 Bishop takes A4 there's
Knight E4 so he plays H6 he's like I
can't afford to give up my D6 Pawn but
good awareness from both players the way
they're handling isn't D6 hanging now
yeah I forgot about that one
both players have their hands in the air
for different reasons I think here
you know wave your hands in the air like
you just don't care but I think that for
gukesh he's stretching he's like oh this
this wrist has done enough work on the
mouse on The chessboard so let's get
ready for the finals yeah I think he
probably will win this final game even
though what's the material only one Pawn
Advantage the eval bar is basically
saying white is more than up a rook
and it helps when you have a Pawn on the
seventh rank it couldn't be captured
because the Knight on the G6 was loose
and now Rook D6 hit the H6 Pawn thread
and Checkmate yeah that's just you and
your accuracy Robert has damn you hey I
see Checkmate in twos I I you know have
gotten pretty good at that over the
years
Rook D6 is that it's a type of move that
is just so strong it knocks you out on
the spot and pranav's gonna resign that
game it's officially over Robert the
bullet has come to an end I mean what a
match that was but it really did get out
of hand uh the the I think the deficit
was too much to overcome in the bullet
it just wasn't ever going to happen what
a result from goo cash
good cash advances the jscc finals he is
our first entrant there he wins by a
final score of 16 and a half to 10 and a
half and this scoreboard does sort of
tell the story because kukesh and the
three plus one and the OnePlus One was
dominant but it doesn't tell the full
story that it was a lead for pranav and
then dukesh went on a roll
exactly that that is the story right
here uh but you can't actually see it by
only looking at that graphic four and a
half four and a half in the five minute
portion doesn't tell the full story
there was a serious lead for pranav
early uh gukesh had to come back I mean
it was actually a really topsy-turvy
match so I think we were treated today
but it just was getting out of hand near
the end and bernav couldn't bring it
back it's like you kind of have that
hope and bullet that oh there's my one
chance to to you know bring it back and
then you realize wait I'm playing a 3150
bullet player who's 13th best player in
the world in classical chess uh yeah
this is actually harder than it looked
yeah that was an uphill battle that he
couldn't quite
um come through with and you can hardly
blame him but it's a single elimination
tournament so our bracket is updated
gukesh he stamps his place in the
championship match he awaits the winner
of his compatriot Roundup sedwani versus
Dennis leswick from Belarus that one is
tomorrow that would be very exciting but
before we get to tomorrow's action
that's a day away we are going to take a
quick break and we return we will have
gukesh on for an interview so chat now's
your time submit your questions ask away
we would love to bring some featured
chat questions to gukesh and when
returned for this break it will be an
interview with our jscc finalist kukesh
foreign
what what
[Music]
people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves
a great coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back you just repeat that again so a
good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's and so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of
self-knowledge the self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate the alert and occur
as as players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know the Roy Lopez or
even though the 14th move of the Roy
Lopez or because you couldn't execute a
rook upon that and yes of course these
attack these are technical things that
you need to win chess games but games
have also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan uh you know and I tell the story
many times laspasky lost they were all
championships have chosen in
1966. goes back to baffinic and
he says you know why did why did I lose
now uh people many people may not know
but spasky was an incredibly talented
chess player right in many ways he's
considered one of the first Universal
chess player he can attack like Tao and
he can defend like patrosion but he
loses this match and Buffet told him uh
the great talented Boris basket uh did
you study butrosion
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself in the
Thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
sebasket
and so he had to take the time and
recognize that he needed to understand
petrosion beating you means I must
understand you chess is a conversations
it's a dialogue between the two chess
players so by 1969 he knew what to
expect at the chessboard he has he has
studied uh the Trojan and he eventually
becomes uh the 10th uh world champion
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it is a pleasure to be joined by our
first finalists for the 2023 Junior
speed Chess Championship
huge congratulations that was a
fantastic performance but my first
question has to be about the start of
the match you were down by three points
how did you write the ship and it were
you able to storm back and then take the
lead
yeah it was a very unexpected fact I I
thought anyways I'll I mean I was quite
confident uh even after the start but
yeah it was quite scary I didn't expect
it to be so tough but uh
yeah after the break I managed to just
freshen up and play some good chess
yeah no you definitely changed some
stuff after the five minute portion it
was clear I wanted to ask you about
online chess in general good cash do you
play a lot of online chess because we
all know you as just being so good at
classical chess we've seen all your big
results there but you play online chess
a lot
and not so much actually uh I have I
mostly play some
uh CCT events but uh
I don't I almost never play casual chess
online
um it's not something that I enjoy a lot
but I'm trying to be uh trying to get
better at this one also
even if you don't enjoy it so much
you're extremely good at it so you just
won your second match in a row against
another strong player and a question I
have for you actually is about an over
the board event you just played Norway
chess was a nice success for you you had
a great showing it was very impressive
how did you enjoy playing classical and
then if the game was a draw heading to
Armageddon
yeah first of all it was a huge
experience for me playing in Norway and
it was
I was quite happy about the performance
I think it the tournament went quite
well and
uh the Armageddon was fun especially
since I did so well it's uh
it was a lot of fun
yeah it was really fun to watch so if
there's that going for you as well I
wanted to ask you again about this match
I don't know if you noticed this good
cash but there was a moment in this
match where black won almost like 10
games in a row did you notice that first
of all and then you know did was that
playing into your choices with white at
all
uh yeah I was uh I did the think about
it uh I don't know with white it was
just so odd that both of us were getting
terrible positions out of the opening uh
with white
and uh
yeah maybe I don't know it was just
playing in both of our heads maybe or
I don't know it's easier to just uh
uh respond to what happens opponent is
doing in bullet I I don't know what's
the reason but yeah I did notice
well speaking of bullet chess our first
featured chat question comes from gabar
Singh and the question was how do you
practice to improve your bullet
performance because you had a great
showing for somebody who doesn't play
online chess all that much for fun
yeah I
I didn't really practice uh practice
much actually I did some puzzles but uh
actually uh after Norway I after the
closing ceremony on the final day we
were me and Hikaru were playing some
bullet I mean I got thrashed like
anything but
maybe that helped uh helped him
yeah I think uh you know getting a
chance to play with one of the the best
bullet players in the world has got to
help somehow
um we have another feature chat question
from Jameson 1227 he wants to know uh
gukesh have you ever trained with pranav
and are you guys friends there was a
video that chess space India posted
recently of you in front of as you know
even younger kids than you guys are
right now uh so do you guys know each
other and do you train together
for
basically since the time I started
playing chess actually
um wow from seven eight years old we
were playing in the same tournaments we
grew up together we traveled to
tournaments together and we also used to
train uh train together but the last few
years we haven't been in in so much
touch but uh
yeah it's nice to see his Improvement as
well especially in faster time controls
has has become uh best nowadays and
faster than conquerors
yeah
yeah he's definitely a monster and I
just want to ask you another question
about that because it sounds like you
two are friends have known each other
for so long since you started playing
chess is it difficult for you to play
against your friends or do you not care
and you only focus on the chest
I in general playing against friends
it's it's not a problem for me but uh
against pranav I
uh actually like uh
I'm actually quite comfortable uh
playing because we've played a lot and
uh I know him pretty well and
I have good score against him so I think
it's uh I'm comfortable playing against
him uh but in general playing friends is
also not not an issue for me we are
we all all the competitors we managed to
fight it out on the board and then we we
can we become friends again after the
game so it's uh it's not really a
problem
yeah I love that mindset and you know
speaking of friends
he's playing in tomorrow's match against
Dennis leswick so we have a featured
chat question from brainstorm18 who do
you think is the favorite between Dennis
and Roanoke
I think raunak has to be a slight
favorite
um his uh
I actually don't know much about lazabik
I've watched some of his matches and
it's always match against Arjun the last
pair but it was really close so
he is also super strong obviously but uh
since I know Roundup so well and I know
how strong he is I think I have to give
Veronica slight uh favorite
oh makes a lot of sense and always
looking out for your friends there I
think I might know the answer to this
question goo cash but I'm still gonna
ask it anyway feature chat question from
Blue Lugia 2 says are you enjoying
playing speed chess as much as classical
um
I have to say not not so much
maybe because I'm just better at
classical but uh
but I actually prefer like over the body
One faster time controls I
prefer with the board and recently I
played this
Armageddon Series in in Berlin and I
enjoyed that even quite a lot
maybe I just prefer
everything over the board than online
but I'm trying to be uh trying to you
know take everything seriously and give
my best everywhere
well you've certainly had great results
online you know you've played the
Champions chess tour and had success
there and you also played in the speed
chess championship last year against
Magnus so uh what was that experience
like I know the result didn't go your
way but did you feel like you gained a
lot from that I mean what is it like to
play the world championship for so many
hours
I mean it was a nice experience
um till I started losing 10 games in a
row
um but uh I guess it was a learning
experience I I mean in general gaining
practice against this super strong
players is always nice
I mean of course I'd like to forget the
result but I'd like to believe it uh
helped me somehow
yeah
well I didn't mean to put you on the
spot there go cash and bring unhappy
memories but you know you're a growing
player you're number 13 in the world in
the live classical ratings and we're
excited to see you in the championship
match here in the junior speed Chess
Championship so congratulations get some
rest we know it's late by you but keep
up the amazing chess you have so many
fans out there
thanks a lot
wow Robert I mean huge congratulations
to good cash what a performance you know
to be down early in the match like that
and just such a championship such a
number one seed mentality didn't look
like it phased him as you can see he's
seated in to the championship matches he
awaits ronak sadwani or Dennis lazovic
to join in he gave the slight nod to his
friend ranik sagwani and if I knew
whether or not he liked basketball I
would have asked him if he was a fan of
Nicole jokic because it sounded eerily
similar like yeah you know I I don't
really care I just do it but not only
does he do it he does it with great
success and what a performance from
gukesh here and just what an awesome
interview that was so fun to hear his
thoughts and he's just improving day
after day
he is and you know I'll Echo your
thoughts there I thought that was a
really enlightening interview just
sharing his thoughts about playing
Magnus playing in other events like the
speed Chess Championship obviously he's
looking to use the jscc as his pathway
back to the SCC so so many interesting
insights there and that he is known
Prana for so many years and that they
still find a way to always compete
against one another and be friends
afterwards yeah I really like that
mindset and speaking of friends of
cash one of his friends is playing
tomorrow and that is Roundup San Juani
as he takes on Dennis lesvik Den Laz as
he's known on chess.com he's won a
couple title Tuesdays he's a fantastic
player and Roanoke saidwani he's made a
name for himself especially in the
online sphere he's had some great
tournaments he's always near the top in
title Tuesdays and he recently won a
match against Nigel short it was very
one-sided that was in person but he's
playing very well and he is a friend at
gukesha so he's ruining him on and
Amanda's gukesh said he may root for his
friends off the board but if he does in
fact face radhik sawani in the
championship match we know he will not
take him lightly and he will have no
problems playing his friends that's
right I think that is the best mentality
to have and I like that he gave him the
credit you know that he definitely
deserves I feel like Raonic said one
he's so strong you just listed some of
his accolades there but he's one of
those players it's just flies under
everyone's radar I feel like because
India is such a strong talented chess
country just doesn't get enough credit
so it's nice to see kukesh handing him
his flowers there a little bit as well
so we'll see who he matches up against
in the championship match but you know
what a match today uh Robert against
yeah that's tomorrow's discussion who
will win who will face good cash right
now it's all about gokash who is number
13 in the world in live readings and
classical chess and shout out to pranav
who deserves a lot of credit for putting
up a great fight and surprising gukesh
at the start of the match so until
tomorrow we say goodbye to all the many
fans out there we appreciate you tuning
in for your support and tomorrow you
will see Radix edwani versus here at the
Juniors pizzas championship
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you